tous passé un mail en lui disant ben
voila je suis intéressé par vos travaux
et puis je travaille une petite
association qui se pose beaucoup de
questions sur comment faire pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de leur
ferme
comment gérer au mieux les vos sources
et ça correspond au thème de bon travail
donc est-ce que vous accepteriez de
venir admirer en nous et être payé en
fromage voilà et dut gea même très
gentil disons que ben ali était ok parce
qu'il aimait le comté et le jour dit
voilà et que ça criait mais le mans et
donc c'est vraiment une chance pour nous
de pouvoir vous accueillir ce soir
donc j'ai lu sur le site internet que
vous êtes ingénieur des mines
vous êtes consultant en énergie et
climat
vous enseignez aussi à l'école des mines
de paris tech vous avait cofondé donc la
société carbone 4 avec qui j'ai fait le
bilan carbone individuel avec maïs et au
bout donc qu'elle 24 c'est un cabinet de
conseil spécialisé la transition
énergétique et l'adaptation aux
changements climatiques
vous avez également fondé l'association
de gym project un think tank ou un
laboratoire d'idées qui a pour objectif
de contribuer à l'atténuation du
changement climatique la réduction de la
dépendance de l'économie aux énergies
possibles
voilà et vous êtes parfois de plus en
plus moi parce que ça fait longtemps que
vous martelez le disco vous êtes parfois
énervé lorsque vous constatez que la
plupart des personnes surtout celles qui
sont en situation de responsabilité ne
prennent pas le temps de lire de
comprendre par rapport à ce qui se passe
en matière de sciences sur justement les
enjeux qui concernent les économies car
sonné et puis le changement climatique
pas donc c'est c'est aussi
parce que c'est un thème qui a fait rage
pour la culture aujourd'hui parce que ça
oui l'agriculture est fortement
dépendant des énergies fossiles
ça peut elle peut aussi être
productrices d'énergie elle peut aussi
atténuer les effets des changements
climatiques
mais le problème est très complexe parce
que je voudrais approchez pas de manière
globale et j'ai dit mot très honnêtement
nous les acteurs - en tant qu'animatrice
même si nous réfléchissons beaucoup
d'autres dessus nous n'avons pas
forcément par quel bout prendre ça donc
le fait de vous demander d'intervenir ce
soir c'est aussi pour nous apporter de
la connaissance de l'information de la
compréhension parce que je crois que
c'est la première étape avant de pouvoir
passer à la prise des décisions
alors je disais donc que l'agriculture
utilise du désir au carbure pas du
pétrole en l'occurrence c'est ça que je
vais essayer d'expliquer de manière
extrêmement il ya énormément la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles est
extrêmement forte au genre agriculture
moderne
c'est ça que je vais essayer d'illustrer
avec cette planche donc je le disais
dans l'exploitation
là en l'occurrence on prend une
exploitation qui a démis production
végétale
vous avez déjà une première source de
dépendance aux hydrocarbures qui est le
carburant consommé par le machinisme
agricole
il se trouve que dans beaucoup
d'exploitations vous avez consommé
également de l'électricité alors si
jamais une très très grosse dépense
d'électricité même dans une exploitation
laitière est par ailleurs en france
l'électricité n'est pas une grande
source de consommation d'hydrocarbures
mais dans d'autres pays ça peut être le
cas puisque 40% de l'électricité
mondiale est faite au charbon et 25% est
faite avec du gaz mais en france pour
c'est pas tellement ça concerne pas
énormément le la culture après on va
parler de quelque chose qui par contre
concerne directement l'agriculture qui
sont les intrants il ya deux grandes
familles d'intrants comme vous le savez
en agriculture vous avez les engrais et
les phytosanitaires et il se trouve que
dans un cas comme de l'autre
c'est des dérivés de la pétrochimie ou
de la gaz au chili
alors si je suis un peu plus précis les
engrais azotés sont fabriqués à partir
d'ammoniaque et l'ammoniac est fabriqué
à partir d'hydrogène se trouve peut-être
entendu parler de l'hydrogène comme
étant l'énergie du futur alors en fait
l'hydrogène s'est tue c'est une molécule
qu'on produit dès aujourd'hui et on la
produit avec gaz naturel le gaz naturel
vous le savez c'est à une molécule qui
contient un atome de carbone et quatre
atomes d'hydrogène ch4 méthane c'est le
même la même molécule est ce qu'on fait
pour obtenir d'hydrogène c'est qu'on
associe ça avec de l'eau l'oxygène de
l'eau va aller récupérer le carbone du
méthane et on va avoir l'hydrogène qui
va rester dans votre côté et qui va être
disponible pour faire de la manière qu
ensuite alors cette ce processus est
très intensifs en énergie et très
émissifs en co2 pour faire une tonne
d'hydrogène il faut y mettre 10 tonnes
de co2 est ensuite avec cet hydrogène on
va fabriquer l'ammoniac et l'ammoniac
lui il va permettre de fabriquer les
ammonitrates telle allure et enfin tous
les engrais azotés
il se trouve que à l'hectare la première
consomag le premier poste de
consommation d'hydrocarbures est le
premier poste d'émission de co2 pour les
grandes cultures
c'est pas du tout le machinisme agricole
c'est le gaz qui est utilisé pour la
fabrication des engrais azotés
vous avez également les phytosanitaires
qui sont tous ceux des molécules
organiques 1 donc les phytosanitaires
sont fabriqués avec des dérivés de la
pétrochimie
donc là vous avez une deuxième
dépendance au pétrole et au gaz dans les
intrants ensuite vous avez une petite
dépendance liée au fait que ces intrants
il faut les amener jusqu'à dans
l'exploitation et ça ça demande des
camions qui utilise du pétrole après une
fois que vous avez la production de
votre champ il faut la sortir du champ
pour l'amener à l'étape suivante alors
l'étape suivante ça peut être des
animaux qu'on va nourrir avec ces
végétaux comme vous le savez l'essentiel
de la surface agricole en france sert à
nourrir des animaux
une bonne partie des pâturages donc là
ya pas de transport intermédiaire on
veut lavage dans le champ mais vous avez
tous les champs de maïs par exemple tous
les champs de maïs fourrage servent à
nourrir des animaux et là il ya du
transport intermédiaire en fait ça va
pas directement chez les animaux ça va
d'abord dans des usines qui servent à
fabriquer des aliments pour animaux puis
ensuite dans les dans les exploitations
c'est également le cas d'une bonne
partie du blé qui sert à faire de
l'alimentation animale
et puis c'est le cas d'une partie
d'autres cultures par exemple les pois
vous en avez une partie qui va dans
l'alimentation animale etc
une fois que vous avez engraisser vos
animaux et bien vous avez de nouveau des
transports pour amener les produits
animaux dans des endroits où ils vont
être transformées alors c'est clair que
quand on est le lait des vaches a compté
dans la fruitières à comté
ça fait pas un très très grand parcours
entre les deux mais par contre quand
vous avez tous les poulets de france où
tous les cochons de france qui sont
élevées en bretagne alors pas tous mais
pas loin
à ce moment vous avez beaucoup de
transport derrière pour amener ça dans
des usines de transformation et ensuite
à l'aval des usines de transformation
vers le consommateur final
vous avez également les produits
végétaux qui peuvent aller directement
dans les usines de transformation
derrière lesquels vous allez allez chez
le consommateur final et le consommateur
final lui va également utiliser des
énergies fossiles en l'occurrence il va
utiliser du gaz pour cuire le ces
aliments et il va aussi utiliser de
l'électricité qui à nouveau dans un
certain nombre de pays utilisent du
charbon et du gaz pour sa production
donc ce que vous voyez sur ce petit
graphique c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui
le système agricole moderne il est
devenu extrêmement dépendant des
hydrocarbures et en particulier du
pétrole et du gaz pour fonctionner et en
fait ce que je vais vous montrer
maintenant c'est que les machines
utilisant du pétrole et du gaz
en fait ont remplacé les paires de bras
et les paires de jambes et les animaux
de trait que vos lointains prédécesseurs
utilisait il ya quelques siècles alors
en particulier on va le voir au travers
de la quantité de
la puissance vers la capacité à
transformer l'environnement quand on
compare vous c'est à dire des êtres
humains et les auxiliaires que nous
sommes aujourd'hui capables de mobiliser
à notre profit les auxiliaires mécanique
évidemment si vous faites
l'ascension alors c'est pas exactement à
côté de chez vous mais enfin pas très
loin on va dire qui consiste à aller de
munster au sommet du kastelberg pas très
loin quatre fois dans la journée
vous allez développer pour faire ça une
puissance donc en gros vous fait 4000
mètres de dénivelé dans la journée et
bien vous allez développer une puissance
moyenne de l'ordre de 100 watts avec vos
jambes quand vous faites ce genre
d'ascension
donc on peut montrer qu'un être humain
au travail qui mobilise ses muscles il
est capable de développer une puissance
musculaire de puissance mécanique qui
est de l'ordre d'une centaine de watts
pour les jambes sur quelques heures et
d'une dizaine de watts pour les bras
alors maintenant on va pas directement
parlé du machinisme agricole mais de
quelque chose qui en est à laval en
l'occurrence d'un mixeur à soupe
puisque quand agriculture produits des
patates et les poireaux il peut prendre
lé envie à certains de mélanger tout ça
avec un big sera souple ça fait du vélo
et bien votre mixeur à soupe
si vous regardez la puissance qu'il a
ses quelques centaines de watts sera
souple que celui que j'ai chez moi il
doit faire 350 watts ce qui veut dire
qu'au moment où j'appuie sur le bouton
unique sera souple a en fait c'est comme
si j'avais 4 personnes 4 cyclistes bien
entraînés qui se mettaient à pédaler
pour moi et à me fournir l'énergie
mécanique de la pédalage pour que je
puisse fixer la soupe quand après avoir
fait des tâches partout sur le sol de la
cuisine d'un fragment l'aspirateur
terrible pour les tâches dessous donc
quand après avoir fait des tâches
partout j'ai besoin de passer
l'aspirateur là mon aspirateur lui il a
plutôt une puissance équivalente à celle
d'une dizaine de paires de jambes de
cyclistes de l'ordre de 1000 watts et là
on va arriver chez vous voilà un engin
vous connaissez bien à tracteur si vous
regardez la puissance du moteur pour
autant que vous la connaissiez pas parce
que je suis sûr que vous la connaissez
par coeur
vous allez vous rendre compte que ces
quelques dizaines de kilos watts alors
ça c'est pas un très très gros tracteurs
si vous avez si vous avez un céréalier
dans la bosse pas rajouter 1 0 mais pas
loin et bien un tracteur de quelques
dizaines de kilowatts
en fait il a la force de traction de
quelques centaines de paires de jambes
ou de quelques dizaines d'animaux de
trêve donc là vous êtes en train de
regarder un engin qui a considérablement
contribué à dépeupler les campagnes tout
simplement parce qu'il a remplacé la
puissance musculaire des gens que vous
aviez là qu'il n'était plus nécessaire
dès lors que cet engin là était capable
de les remplacer avec une seule personne
dans la cabine de conduite
voilà d'autres engins qui sont
aujourd'hui très commun dans la vie
courante et qui ont aussi contribué à
remplacer des gens avec des d'efficacité
considérablement supérieur oui par
exemple un engin de travaux publics
il a un moteur qui est d'une puissance
qui est pas très loin de celle d'un
tracteur s'est pas excusé les puissances
pas très éloigné et si vous comparez sa
non pas des gens mais à des braves vous
rendez compte qu'un engin comme ça en
fait vous manipule de la terre à peu
près comme si vous aviez quelques
milliers d'ouvriers pour vous faire le
même boulot
le camion dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure et qui vous sert à transporter
les productions intermédiaire au final
jusque vers les consommateurs et à
ramener chez vous les intrants a baladés
des animaux et c est bien lui il [ __ ]
comme quelques milliers de fois une
paire de jambes et c'est notamment grâce
à ces engins là que nous avons pu
fabriquer des villes où rien de plus
mais où vous pouvez nourrir tout le
monde parce que c'est grâce à des engins
comme ça qu avec très peu de monde on
peut faire circuler la nourriture sur
des très grandes distances et donc
concentré des très grandes quantités de
gens là où ils ne poussent rien les
villes modernes n'existerait pas sans
les transports modernes elle
n'existerait pas non plus sans les
tracteurs modernes c'est ce que je vais
vous montrer après aujourd'hui la
totalité de la civilisation urbaine
repose sur le fait que ce sont les
machines qui travaillent pour nous
notamment dans la production agricole
parce qu'il faut manger quand bien même
quand on est en ville de la nourriture
ne sent pas du supermarché et qu'il faut
transporter cette nourriture jusque dans
les justes dans les vide il faut savoir
qu'en france par exemple un camion sur
trois qui circulent transporte quelque
chose qui se mange
alors quand je dis quelque chose qui se
mange c'est par extension
je mets le foin et les animaux sur pied
mais enfin un tiers des camions qui
circulent ont un lien avec la fonction
alimentaire enfin ici vous avez une
aciérie alors l'aciérie elle est
directement à votre service parce que
c'est grâce à la série qu'on fait le
tracteur que vous voyez là et même la
fourche
voilà donc l'aciérie elle elle a une
puissance
enfin le laminoir plus exactement parce
que là c'est l'exemple que j'ai pris
c'est celui d'un ami noir et bien le
laminoir vous savez qui c'est qui sert à
écraser des tôles d'acier il à l'habit
noir moderne
il a la même puissance mécanique que si
je mettais la totalité de l'île de
france au travail avec un marteau dans
la main pour taper sur des tôles toute
la journée
donc un seul laminoir comme celui qu'on
a par exemple à dunkerque ou celui qu'on
a à fos sur mer en france il est capable
de remplacer 10 millions d'ouvriers au
travail s'ils n'avaient que leurs bras à
leur disposition et grâce à cela me noir
vous allez faire le tracteur qui va
remplacer une partie des agriculteurs et
le camion qui permet d'envoyer tout ça
est un système est ce que vous voyez
c'est que nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
un système de machine dont vous faites
partie et qui a permis de
considérablement transformé le monde
dans lequel nous vivons
alors voilà un tout petit échantillon
des machines qui nous entourent
aujourd'hui et ses machines
quand vous regardez en fait ce qu'elles
ont fait pour nous eh bien vous vous
rendez compte qu'elles ont transformé
l'homme en robocop superman ironman
appelez le comme vous voulez pour de
vrai c'est à dire que la main gauche
d'iron man là c'est le tractopelle qui
est là qui soulève des charges dix mille
fois plus lourde que ce que son bras
pourrait soulever son oeil droit là
c'est le télescope qui voit beaucoup
plus loin que la treille son genou
gauche c'est le train qui avance très
très vite son pied droit c'est l'avion
qui avance encore plus vite et c est
donc en fait les machines modernes
elles ont permis de rendre l'homme
surpuissant par rapport à son
environnement c'est bien ça le problème
du reste parce que en étant surpuissant
par rapport à notre environnement on a
la capacité de transformer beaucoup plus
vite que l'environnement n'est capable
de s'adapter
si on fait un calcul en pratique
on se rend compte que toutes ces
machines avec leur nourriture
particulière l'énergie j'appelle parfois
des croquettes pour la chine c'est
exactement ça eh bien elles ont été
capables de démultiplier la puissance
musculaire par un facteur de l'ordre de
quelques centaines à l'échelle mondiale
dit autrement aujourd'hui
la production économique mondiale elle
et quelques centaines de fois supérieurs
à ce que nous pourrions faire si nous
n'avions que nos bras et aux jambes et
ça c'est grâce à l'énergie que nous
l'avons donc l'énergie en fait nous a
transformés en aéro de bannu un superman
et elle a transformé tous les secteurs
dans de l'activité humaine comme l a
transformé massivement l'agriculture à
cause de ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire les usines dans
l'oeil les usines de phytosanitaires et
le machinisme ici vous avez la
traduction économique j'ai envie de dire
alors c'est un truc qui est important
pour vous ce que je vais dire maintenant
parce que vous allez voir que vous
faites partie des gens qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas significativement moins bien
payés que les financiers de wall street
est en fait c'est aller c'est dû à
l'énergie cette histoire là et vous
allez voir donc ici vous avez la
première partie de cette ce que je suis
en train de la fin de cette conclusion
j'ai envie de dire qui est que quand on
regarde dans le monde sur quasiment 60
ans maintenant comment évolue la
production économique mondiale
on appelle le pib gross domestic product
en anglais c'est la même chose
je suis désolé temps en temps des
graphiques son bail d'avoir des
audiences anglophone et je suis fini en
trombe utilise qu'un seul graphique donc
ici vous avez le pib mondial en
milliards de dollars
et ici vous avez la quantité d'énergie
qu'on utilise c'est à dire en fait la
quantité de machines qu'on a mis à votre
service c'est sur l'énergie eia vous
vous rendez compte que la production
économique mondiale en fait c'est à peu
de choses près proportionnelle à la
quantité de machines qu'on a mise en
service quand le canton n'a plus
d'énergie pour faire fonctionner plus de
machines le pib augmente et en fait on
peut le voir aussi dans un certain
nombre de pays
quand on a moins d'énergie disponible
pour faire fonctionner - imagine mal le
pib diminue c'est ce qui s'est passé en
grèce c'est ce qui se passe en italie
c'est ce qui se passe en espagne c'est
ce qui commence à se passer en france et
donc en fait la croissance du pib elle
durera pas indéfiniment elle devra aussi
longtemps que la croissance de
l'approvisionnement énergétique modulo
quelque chose
puis quand l'approvisionnement
énergétique commencera à baisser de
manière significative à le pib baissera
aussi de manière significative que ça
nous plaise ou pas cette énergie que
nous utilisons aujourd'hui elle est
majoritairement possible mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
en fait on a coutume de présenter
l'énergie renouvelable comme étant
l'énergie de l'avenir mais il faut se
souvenir que c'est surtout l'énergie du
passé
ici vous avez un tableau une vie
d'artiste on va dire d'un monde 100 %
renouvelable et ça le pot strictement
aucun problème d'être 100% renouvelable
ici vous en avez un exemple quand vous
allez là transports terrestres 100%
renouvelable avec un cheval
renouvelables ici vous avez un transport
maritime sans qu'on s'en rende ouvrables
avec une barque en bois renouvelables et
un batelier qui pousse une perche
renouvelables il n'y a pas de boulin
fonctionnant avec du vent renouvelables
mais il pourrait y en avoir
et vous voyez ce fleuve renouvelables
peut également actionner d'autres
moulins ailleurs servant avant dans la
farine de façon parfaitement audible
donc en fait l'énergie fossile est une
novation qui nous a fait sortir de
l'énergie renouvelable et c'est bien ça
qui a street qui a fortement augmenté
notre emprise sur l'environnement et non
pas l'inversé donc les énergies
renouvelables c'est peut-être l'avenir
mais en tout cas de façon absolument
certaine c'est le passé et quand on
regarde ce qu'on a fait dans tous les
domaines d'activité qui nous concerne
c'est qu'elle quel que soit le domaine
depuis quelques siècles ç'a toujours été
de passer des renouvelables aux fossiles
on avait par exemple une marine à voile
renouvelables qui servait de temps en
temps à transporter quelques cargaison
de blé par exemple les îles shetland
avait besoin de faire venir le plus
c'est pas très bien là bas ça venait par
bateau à voile eh bien nous avons
fossilisés la marine c'est à dire que
maintenant il n'y a plus quasiment plus
un bateau à voile qui circulent enfin si
pour faire le vendée globe mais sinon
pas pour transporter des marchandises
parce que c'était quand même beaucoup
plus pratique pour transporter des
grandes quantités vite pour pas cher
nous avions des transports terrestres
parfaitement renouvelables vous pouvez
voir ici avec un cheval renouvelables
manger de l'herbe renouvelables le
cheval renouvelables et envir est lui
viennent manger en fin de vie quand il y
avait des animaux très y avait des
boucheries chevalines maintenant il ya
plus d'animaux très il ya plus de
boucherie chevaline et nous avons
remplacé sa part un transport à pétrole
parce que c'est beaucoup plus efficace
alors avec ce genre de transport vous
pouviez
avoir des villes qui étaient beaucoup
plus petit parce que à l'époque où on
avait ce genre de transport et peu de
moyens de conservation pour
l'agriculture une ville en gros elle
peut être nourri par le surplus
agricoles qui est dégagée dans un disque
dont le rayon et quelques jours de
transport à pied ou à cheval
à l'époque où la productivité agricole
était faible et où les transports
étaient lents et bien le surplus
agricoles du disque concernés étaient
faibles et donc vous pouviez mettre en
ville des gens qui faisait pas pousser
leur nourriture en petites quantités
c'est la raison pour laquelle lutèce
avec quelques on va dire quelques
dizaines de milliers d'habitants paris
la renaissance c'était de l'ordre de 100
milles et il a fallu attendre ce genre
de choses comme je le disais tout à
l'heure pour qu'on fasse des grosses
villes donc les grosses villes ne seront
pas plus durable que le pétrole quand
l'énergie fossile commencera à se faire
rares les grandes villes vont souffrir
et ça va devenir pas très drôle
probablement dans ces endroits là voilà
une agriculture sans qu'on s'en rende
ouvrables je ne faut pas je ne vous fais
pas de dessin et on l'a remplacé comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure par une
agriculture tout à fait faux cils qui
permet d'avoir besoin de beaucoup moins
de monde et beaucoup moins d'animaux
dans les champs ça a eu un autre gros
avantage cette affaire là c'est que ça a
libéré de la surface pour les hommes
parce que ces bestioles alors besoin de
manger alors certes vous finissez par
les manger en fin de vie mais enfin dans
l'intervalle ça a quand même besoin de
manger
alors que cette bête là elle mange du
sous sol donc elle vous laisse tout le
sol en surface disponible pour nourrir
des sommes donc entre le fait que
l'agriculture est devenue beaucoup plus
productifs grâce aux intrants et à la
mécanisation et au fait qu'on a récupéré
les surfaces agricoles pour nous alors
qu'avant elles étaient dévolues à ce
genre de bestioles on a pu fortement
augmenté la population mondiale grâce
aux hydrocarbures
vous avez ici un l'industrie des temps
anciens parfaitement renouvelables donc
vous voyez un moulin avec une roue en
bois renouvelables utilisant de l'eau
renouvelables et puis on s'est dit que
quand même pour faire un tracteur c'est
quand même beaucoup plus commode d'avoir
une industrie fossiles ça allait
beaucoup plus vite et ça coûterait
beaucoup moins cher
tout ce que je viens de vous dire a
notamment contribué à modifier de façon
très forte
la structure de l'emploi et donc à des
peuples et les campagnes donc en fait le
dépeuplement des campagnes
c'est un processus qui est la
conséquence de l'arrivée de l'énergie
quelque part
est ce que c'est ce que je vais vous
montrer pour le cas français et après je
vais généraliser partout dans le monde
l'exode rural est une conséquence de
l'arrivée de l'approvisionnement
énergétique à vendre vous avez ici la
quantité de gens qui travaillent en
france par secteur sur deux siècles
c'est une série assez longue alors ce
que vous voyez c'est que il ya deux
siècles donc en 1800 les deux tiers de
la population active sont auchan ans de
moins donc agriculteurs paysans pas
exactement quel est le terme le plus le
piquant sacré et à cette époque là est
bien un tiers de la population active se
partagent en gros à parité dans
l'industrie et le bâtiment
alors donc c'est des artisans
essentiellement à cette époque là
évidemment c'est pas des ouvriers de
laminoir c'est essentiellement des
artisans et dans les services alors les
services qu'est ce qu'on a à cette
époque là bas on a déjà beaucoup de
commerçants on a déjà quelques banquiers
et puis on a beaucoup de personnel de
maison
donc tout ça c'est dans les services bon
là aussi les quelques instituteurs donc
ce que vous voyez là c'est la
répartition de l'emploi il ya deux
siècles
ce que vous voyez c'est que jusqu'en
1850 la population globale augmente
toutes les catégories d'emploi augmente
mais la population agricole augmente
alors pourquoi ça parce que à cette
époque là l'industrie ne sait pas encore
mais les de fournir en masse de quoi
augmenter la productivité agricole et
par contre on continue à défricher en
france
le minimum forestier arrive en france en
donc là les surfaces à cultiver augmente
et même à productivité constante des
agriculteurs eh bien on peut augmenter
enfin ou plus exactement ça correspond à
une augmentation du nombre de gens qui
travaillent dans le secteur agricole
et puis après l'industrie naissante que
vous voyez ici va amener en quantité
croissante aux agriculteurs des objets
qui vont leur permettre d'augmenter leur
productivité alors à l'époque les objets
en question c'est des routes cercle et
en faire par exemple qui permettent de
transporter plus facilement
ne serait-ce que de transporter plus
facilement les caps toutes sortes pour
aller fertiliser les champs dont les
déjections des animaux les déjections
des hommes et vous avez également on
commence à avoir des socs de charrues
qui sont plus performants des colliers
de trait qui sont plus performants et c
est ça ça permet à la fois d'augmenter
la production agricole tout en paix tout
en ne nécessitant plus autant de gens
qui vont travailler dans les champs
donc en fait l'essor industriel qui est
celui des forges et de l'industrie et
qui est également l'essor de l'énergie
puisque l'énergie en fait c'est utiliser
des machines et biens va conduire à
diminuer la quantité d'agriculteurs dans
les choix parce que par contre la
surface à cultiver n'augmente pas la
surface à cultiver étant toujours la
même et chaque agriculteur étant capable
de faire plus de travail avec ses
prothèses des temps modernes qui sont
les machines et bien on a besoin de
moins de gens dans les champs du coup on
peut en mettre plus ailleurs notamment
parce que l'approvisionnement
énergétique croissant permet aussi de
quantité de d'utiliser des machines
pardon qui vont exploiter toutes les
ressources qui nous entoure les minerais
le calcaire pour faire du ciment etc
après la seconde guerre mondiale les
machines vont arriver directement dans
les champs ses détracteurs dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et la pétrochimie
ce que la chimie organique c'est après
la seconde guerre mondiale va également
se mêler de la partie et pour vos
collègues français revoit les applis
comme ça qu'ils cultivent des céréales
on va assister quasiment à quintuplement
du rendement céréalier en l'espace de
quelques décennies seulement entre 1945
et 1975 dans le dans les grandes plaines
fertiles de la beauce et donc ça c'est
les machines c'est comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure ses détracteurs les
vignes d'angle alors comme le ya de plus
en plus d'énergie comme j'ai tout à
l'heure dans le même temps que l'on
diminue la quantité de gens dans les
champs en les remplaçant par des
machines
eh bien on peut mettre d'autres machines
au travail ailleurs est une machine au
travail c'est un emploi
à chaque fois que vous avez une machine
au travail vous avez besoin d'un ouvrier
pour donner des ans dans la machine ou
pour s'en occuper
et donc vous avez de plus en plus de
machines dans l'industrie qui vont
fabriquer de plus en plus de trucs et de
machins des tourniquets tafer la vie des
aspirateurs comme chantait boris vian
donc vous en avez de plus en plus
jusqu'au choc pétrolier et à ce moment
au moment du choc pétrolier ce qui va se
passer c'est que l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personnes s'arrêtent de
croître
donc le parc de machines en service par
personne en puissance s'arrête de
croître mais par contre ça va être le
plus en plus fait de très très grosses
machines de très grosse puissance
unitaire
donc vous allez avoir une puissance
totale à notre disposition qui bouge pas
beaucoup mais qui va se constituer de
machines de plus en plus grosse et donc
on a besoin de moins en moins de monde
pour les piloter
donc vous allez avoir ce grand paradoxe
après le choc pétrolier qui est que la
production industrielle va continuer
d'augmenter
avec pourtant des effectifs dans
l'industrie qui vont se mettre à baisser
à cause de ce que je viens d'expliquer
donc ici vous voyez comment l'énergie en
l'espace de deux siècles a totalement
déformé la structure de l'emploi est ce
que je vous montre pour la france c'est
à dire que la population active dans le
domaine agricole est passé de deux tiers
de la population à 2% de la population
et bien en fait c'est répétitif partout
c'est à dire dans tous les pays dans le
monde où l'énergie arrive vous avez
exactement les mêmes processus qui se
constitue ce qui s'observe de moins en
moins d'agriculteurs de plus en plus
d'ouvriers de plus en plus de services
et en particulier une civilisation
tertiaire c'est à dire avec énormément
de gens dans les services vous vous
rendez compte que cette utilisation
qui demande beaucoup d'énergie et pas du
tout mais utilisation qui évite beaucoup
d'énergie et ces gens là où est ce
qu'ils sont ils sont dans les villes
donc l'arrivée de l'énergie abondante a
permis la création des villes
le mode de vie urbain n'est pas
contrairement à ce qu'on se dit souvent
un mode de vie sobres en énergie le fait
d'avoir constitué des grosses villes est
en fait une marque de l'énergie
augmentent alors
dernièrement on a également rajouté
pour avoir énormément de gens dans les
services il faut avoir énormément de
production physique sous jacente parce
que sinon les gens n'ont rien à faire je
vais prendre un exemple idiots qui est
la voiture
si aujourd'hui l'industrie automobile
s'arrête alors certes ça mais les
ouvriers de l'industrie automobile au
chômage dans une petite partie de la
population active mais savait également
au chômage tous les gens qui vendent des
voitures qui eux sont dans les services
tous les gens qui financent les ventes
de voitures neuves qui est au 120 rue
service tous les gens qui apprennent à
conduire qui sont dans les services tous
les gens qui assurent les voitures qui
sont dans les skis et c'est donc vous
voyez que en fait
et évidemment tous les enseignants qui
apprennent à financer des voitures
assurées des voitures et c'est donc ce
que vous voyez c'est que les services en
fait ne peuvent pas exister sans un flux
industriels sous jacent ça n'existe pas
de penser qu'on peut avoir une
civilisation avec juste des services en
fait les services n'existent que quand
vous avez énormément de produits qui se
baladent dans tous les sens et que vous
avez besoin de beaucoup beaucoup de gens
pour admis dié pour administrer la
complexité de cette affaire là le quand
là quand l'énergie commence à faire
défaut à ce moment vous voyez arriver
quelque chose qui s'appelle le chômage
c'est à dire que moins de machines en
service c'est moins de gens pour avoir
besoin de faire fonctionner ces machines
à vous pourriez dire s'il ya moins de
machines en service ça libère de
l'espace pour remettre de la production
des hommes
certes mais le différend de la
différence entre la puissance d'une
machine et la puissance d'un homme et
elle vous avez vu tout à l'heure des
centaines des milliers de fois que en
fait malheureusement si vous avez une
machine de moins qui travaille ça ne ce
n'est toujours pas économiquement
intéressant de remplacer sa part des
milliers de gens que vous allez devoir
payer
donc en fait la première des choses qui
se passent quand l'approvisionnement
énergétique commence à faire défaut
c'est que vous voyez le chômage augmente
et est en fait en france
la courbe du chômage reflètent à peu de
choses près la variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
c'est malheureusement le premier
déterminant et de très loin je vous ai
raconté ça pour la france mais vous
voyez ici exactement la même chose dans
un certain nombre d'autres pays alors
ils skient je vous montre par exemple
l'inde
sur ce graphique vous avez sur le lac
sont horizontales la fraction de la
population active qui est dans
l'agriculture et en ordonnée je suis
désolé j'ai pas mis l'énergie mais c'est
presque pareil j'ai mis des tonnes de
co2 par personne c'est à dire le p
le gaz et le charbon consommé par
personne ce que vous voyez c'est que en
1991 l'inde avait les deux tiers de sa
population dans les champs aujourd'hui
ses 45%
mais dans l'intervalle la quantité de
co2 émise par personne a à peu près
doublé
c'est à dire que la quantité d'énergie
par personne a à peu près doublé donc
plus d'énergie en inde a fait exactement
la même chose que en france à vider en
proportion ça a vidé les compagnies
voilà la même chose en chine
vous voyez en 1991 par dans nos notes
ainsi il ya des belges immigrés donc 12
55% de la population était agricole
aujourd'hui en chine
on est à 20 % seulement et l'explication
de ça c'est l'explosion énergétique que
vous avez eus en chine où on a eu
exactement les mêmes processus que en
occident c'est à dire mécanisation
engrais etc
je voulais dit tout à l'heure une fois
que les gens deviennent ouvriers ou dans
les services ils vont en ville parce que
c'est là que ça se passe
et donc vous voyez quelque chose qui est
exactement la même évolué de là vous
voyez la belle évolution que ce qu'on a
eu en france en chine en l'occurrence la
part des gens en paix dans les services
est passé de 18% à plus de 50% entre
1991 et 2014
c'est aller dans ce sens là et c'est la
conséquence du fait que la quantité
d'énergie par personne sérieuse émission
de co2 par personne ont fortement
augmenté dans l'intervalle et là vous
voyez exactement la même chose pour la
thaïlande
parce que c'est exactement le même genre
de processus camp ouattara
donc ce que le résumé de cette première
partie c'est que l'énergie l'agriculture
en indépendante à tous les niveaux
l'énergie est ce qui a considérablement
fait baisser l'emploi en proportion dans
le monde agricole
c'est ce qui a permis la création des
villes et notamment c'est ce qui permet
aujourd'hui de les nourrir
comme je le disais à cause des camions
si on devait revenir au transport au
porteur
aux personnes qui portent sur leur dos
et aux charrettes à cheval paris
mouraient de faim par exemple qu'avion
meurent de faim possible par exemple ils
sont en train alors ça a également eu
une conséquence pour vos lointains
clients cette histoire là qui est que la
nourriture bien qu'il râle en disant que
ça vaut trop cher vaut en fait de moins
en moins chers et pas un peu moins cher
considérablement moins chers
vous avez ici la part de l'alimentation
dans le budget des ménages
alors c'est aux états unis pourquoi
est-ce que c'est aux états unis alors là
je suis désolé de dire du mal de mon
pays mais c'est tout simplement parce
que quand vous cherchez une série longue
sur le site de l'insee en france vous
mettez un quart d'heure un patron qu'est
ce que vous voulez
alors que quand vous voulez une série
longue sur un site internet aux états
unis en trois clics de souris mais c'est
exactement pareil aux états unis en
france parce que l'énergie a eu même
rôle donc ce que vous voyez c'est que en
1930 le ménages américains dépensent un
quart de ce qu'ils gagnent dans la
nourriture en france à mon avis c'était
un peu au dessus encore à l'époque ce
que vous voyez donc là c'est que 20% de
ses dépenses
c'est à la maison et un petit 5 % c'est
en dehors de la maison donc à cette
époque là on va déjà au restaurant un
petit peu et puis surtout un point
important c'est que en 1930 80 % de la
dépense alimentaire c'est des produits
bruts c'est-à-dire qu'à cette époque-là
on achète quand même assez peu de pots
de moutarde paquets de biscuits de
nutella et de steaks surgelés ce qui se
passe
alors désolé quand ce propos sexiste
mais enfin c'est quand même ça la
réalité sociologique à l'époque ce qui
se passe c'est que madame michu ou
madame milf plus exactement va acheter
aux paysans du coin des poireaux des
patates et des oeufs effet le frichti
pour monsieur smith qui est agriculteur
pour partie et ouvriers pour partie pour
l'essentiel du temps et puis en 2015
en fait la restauration à la maison
aujourd'hui quand ce qu'on compte en
dépenses alimentaires en fait c'est
énormément de choses qui ne sont plus
des aliments donc à ce moment là ce
qu'on paye c'est vraiment des aliments
je vous dis des poireaux et patates
achetée aux paysans du coin là ce que
l'insee va compter c'est le ticket de
caisse
quand vous passez la caisse
enregistreuse de carrefour mais vous
êtes très bien placé pour savoir que
quand dans le ticket de caisse de
carrefour
quand je passe à lormont le camp j'y
vais quasiment jamais mais admettons que
j'y aille ce que je vais payer c'est
tout sauf vous je vais payer la
construction du magasin je vais payer le
salaire de la caissière et du magasinier
je vais payer le salaire du chauffeur
qui a livré les yaourts je vais payer la
valeur ajoutée de l' usine de plastique
qui a fait le pot de yaourt je vais
payer l' agence de pub qui a fait la pub
des yaourts je vais payer les dividendes
des actionnaires de carrefour enfin je
vais payer tout sauf la nourriture que
je viens vraiment d'acheter je vous
ferai pas l'insultent de vous expliquer
que quand j'achète du mauvais compter
dans une grande surface ce qui m'arrive
heureusement très rarement
eh bien je vais le payer allez on va
dire 20 euros le kilo et vous savez très
bien que vous il vous est payé entre le
cas pour le cinquième est fière de ce
prix selon selon la manière dont vous
arrivez à vous débrouiller donc le en
fait là l'essentiel est là encore la
transformation est faible il s'agit de
couper un fromage en morceaux et le lac
sous plastique
si vous regardez une boîte 2 c'est
pareil la fin du striaient lille est
payé 6 centimes en sortie d'élevage une
boîte de 6,6 au 6 36 et je vais
l'acheter un d'euros 56 centimes sortie
d'élevage et je vais l'acheter 1 euro 50
au magasin enfin en surface c'est donc
en fait l'essentiel de ce que vous payez
n'a rien à voir avec de la nourriture
donc en fait la part de la nourriture
elle même quand on achète dans ticket de
caisse
c'est moins de 20% du total et si je
vais me manger une omelette au bistrot
du coin enfin le jour où ils auront le
droit où ils ont été confinés
alors là c'est pire encore je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de mais aussi
sentiment sortie d'élevage si je vais
manger une omelette de 3e ou au bistrot
du coin que à paris je vais payer 5
euros
j'aurais payé 5 euros à plat dans lequel
je 18 centimes de nourriture 3 6 1 3 6 9
à 3,3 au pardon prophétie centimes
donc vous voyez bien que en fait sur
cette série longue
là ce qu'on paye c'est essentiellement
de la nourriture là ce qu'on paye c'est
essentiellement autre chose que de la
nourriture
si je regarde ce que je paye vraiment
pour la nourriture
en fait le prix des aliments il a été
divisé alors facialement parvint est en
fait réellement part encore plus que ça
et en particulier le prix de la viande
lui il a probablement été divisée par 50
puisque à cette époque là on mangeait
trois fois moins de viande deux fois
moins de viande alors pas aux états unis
mais en france c'est sûr que ce qu'on
mange elle a donc le l'énergie a permis
de diviser par un plusieurs dizaines le
coût des aliments
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui pour 10% de
ce que je gagne je mange trois fois plus
de viande que ce que mes grands parents
mangeaient à cette époque là pour un
quart voire plus en france de ce qu'ils
gagnent quasiment la moitié donc les
gens ont tort de râler en disant que la
nourriture et coûte cher en fait la
nourriture ne vaut rien est ce que je
viens de vous expliquer est vrai pour
tous les produits que nous achetons
si vous regardez le coût réel d'une
chemise d'une table d'une chaise d'une
paire de chaussures enfin de tous les
produits qui existait déjà il ya un
siècle
vous vous rendrez compte que exprimé en
fractions de votre budget en part de
votre budget ils ont tous
considérablement baissé et ce qui a
permis cette baisse c'est l'énergie
donc en fait notre pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'énergie parce que c'est les machines
au travail
donc ce que je vous ai raconté dans la
première partie de cette intervention
c'est que mère nature a fourni
gratuitement parce que ça a était
gratuit du pétrole du gaz du charbon et
marginalement des chutes d'eau de
l'uranium et du vent j'insiste sur le
fait que c'est gratuit la formation du
pétrole est gratuite le pétrole c'est
des résidus de plancton qui a vécu dans
la mer entre ya 5 millions d'années et y
as 400 millions d'années
nous n'avons personne n'a payé un
centime pour que le pétrole se forment
donc le pétrole est aussi gratuite le
vent c'est dans les deux cas de figure
ce qui c'est d'aller le chercher qui
coûte quelque chose donc ces
combustibles fossiles ont permis de
mettre des machines en mouvement à
travers leur combustion et ça a permis
de transformer à vitesse accélérée tout
ce qui nous est tombé sous la main pour
fabriquer
à peu près tout ce que nous avons envie
de faire et dernièrement des pantoufles
connecter des poêles à frire connecter
tout un tas de truc absolument essentiel
pour l'existence ça nous a également
permis de déformer la structure des
métiers ça nous a permis de déformer la
structure de l'habitat les gens habitent
en ville pour l'essentiel ça nous a
permis de libérer du temps parce que
comme on est devenus on travaille plus
parce que c'est les machines qui bosse à
notre place alors ce que je dis est pas
tout à fait vrai pour tout le monde mais
globalement et bien ça nous a permis de
partir en vacances cinq semaines par an
ça nous a permis d'avoir les week-ends
ça nous a permis de travailler 35 heures
par semaine
ça nous a permis de faire des études
longues ça nous a permis de prendre
notre retraite tout ça c'est des
conséquences de l'énergie augmentent
il ya deux facteurs limitant à cette
affaire je vais maintenant vous parler
rapidement garder deux facteurs
limitants qui est le changement
climatique il faut pas oublier l'autre
facteur limitant qui est le fait que
comme si ressources ne sont pas
renouvelables
eh bien elles sont condamnées à
s'épuiser c'est à dire que leur
extraction est condamné à passer par un
maximum pour décliner derrière ce qu'ils
disent ce qui est une autre manière de
dire pardon que la décroissance est
inéluctable que ça nous plaise ou que ça
ne nous plaisent pas la question n'est
pas tant de savoir si on va y échapper
la question est plutôt de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on arrivera à s'en accommoder
voilà donc maintenant je vais vous
parler très rapidement du changement
climatique puisqu'il vous concernent de
près alors je vais commencer par ce
camembert
l'agriculture c'est bien de circonstance
de s'occuper des camemberts et ce
camembert vous donnent la part de chaque
activité humaine d'un certain nombre
d'activités humaines dans les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre qui modifie le
climat alors une bonne partie des
émissions 20% environ
c'est le fait des centrales à charbon
une centrale à charbon c'est quoi c'est
un endroit où on brûle du charbon pour
faire de la chaleur
avec cette chaleur on va créer de la
vapeur sous pression et avec cette
vapeur sous pression va faire tourner
une turbine qui entraîne un alternateur
comme dans votre voiture qui va
fabriquer de l'électricité qui va
produire de l'électricité
c'est exactement comme une centrale
nucléaire une centrale à charbon sauf
qu'au lieu de faire la chaleur avec
d'une réaction nucléaire bas on l'a fait
en brûlant du charbon
le charbon brûler le charbon ça fait du
co2 et donc 20% des émissions mondiales
de gaz à effet de serre tougas
confondues y compris le
tanner protoxyde d'azoté et bien vient
des centrales à charbon 7% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est les
centrales à gaz et fuel donc ce même
principe on prend les hydrocarbures ont
les shows on les brûle ça fait de la
vapeur 7 % des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre sont le fait des
cimenteries alors ce qui se passe dans
une cimenterie c'est qu'on prend du
calcaire on le chauffe très très fort ça
qu'on fait dans un four à ciment et ça
casse le calcaire en deux morceaux d'un
côté de la chaux vive et de l'autre côté
du co2 et cette chaux vive on la mélange
à tout un tas de poudre de perlimpinpin
et ça fera du clain caire puis du ciment
donc ça c'est 7 % des émissions
mondiales la cimenterie et l'industrie
la plus émissive c'est la première dès
la première des industriels ici dans le
monde dix pour cent des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est le reste des
émissions directes de l'industrie là
dedans vous avez encore la syrie qui
fait 4 % vous avez le chili qui doit pas
être très loin
après l'industrie manufacturière s'est
beaucoup moins émissifs parce que vous
chauffer très peu et vous utilisez
surtout de l'électricité pour
transformer l'électricité du coup les
émissions sont déjà comptés la 5 % des
émissions mondiales c'est les chaudières
de bâtiments alors ça peut vous paraître
pas beaucoup parce qu'en france c'est
beaucoup plus mais en fait tous les
bâtiments sont pas chauffées par le
monde
et puis en france on n'a pas de centrale
à charbon on a pas on a moins de
centrales à gaz
on n'a pas autant de cimenterie qu en
inde ou en chine et donc ses parts de
camembert là sont beaucoup plus petites
ce qui épice ici il va également y en
avoir des plus petites
ce qui explique que cette part là
puissent être plus rousse 14% des
émissions mondiales c'est les transports
dans lesquelles la flotte mondiale de
voitures c'est 6% la flotte mondiale de
camions c4 et la flotte mondiale de
bateaux c2 et avions avant que id 2 20%
des émissions mondiales c'est
l'agriculture
alors là vous êtes directement concernés
vous allez voir que alors pardon les gaz
qui sont à l'origine de ces émissions
c'est un petit peu le diesel du tracteur
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
mais c'est surtout des gaz qui ne sont
pas du co2 il y en a deux en particulier
le protoxyde d'azoté le méta d'alors le
métal je vous en parlais dans une
planche
ça vient des ruminants et ça vient des
rizières essentiellement mais vous avez
également du protoxyde d'azoté qui est
émis par les sols agricoles alors le
protoxyde d'azoté un gaz qui se dégage
après épandage des engrais azotés donc
les engrais azotés dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure quand on les et pan dans les
champs mais c'est exactement pareil
quand on dépend des déjections animales
dans lesquelles il ya des composés
azotés et bien une partie de ces
composés azotés réagi avec la flore
microbienne du sol et ça vous fait un
gaz qui s'appelle le protoxyde d'azoté
qui est un gaz à effet de serre 300 fois
plus puissant que le co2 qui est émis
par les sols agricoles
vous avez également du méthane qui est
le gage de la putréfaction ces liasses
de la décomposition la fermentation
si vous avez entendu parler des
méthaniseurs les méthaniseurs c'est un
endroit vous fait fermenter des matières
végétales pour produire du méthane qui
est la molécule principale du gaz
naturel ch4 alors du méthane six enfants
naturellement dans les rizières parce
que là vous avez des débris biologique
qui se décompose à l'abri de l'oxygène
de l'air comme dans les marécages et
vous en avez dans les estomacs des
vaches puisque dans pense qu'il ya et
feuillette et bonnet très bad trip et
bien vous avez du méthane qui se forment
et le méthane ressort par là et non pas
par là pour l'essentiel enfin 11 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde
c'est la déforestation à la
déforestation est un processus salon de
l'agriculture pour l'essentiel on coupe
des forêts pour faire des champs et les
deux déterminants principaux de la
déforestation voire essentiel c'est la
croissance démographique plus on est
nombreux plus on fait de surfaces
agricoles et l'augmentation de la part
de viande dans l'alimentation puisque
plus on veut manger de viande et plus on
a besoin de surfaces pour fournir les
végétaux qui vont nourrir ces bestioles
là enfin vous avez 7 % des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui viennent de
processus divers la gestion des déchets
les fuites de fluides frigorigènes
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que
l'agriculture et sont déterminants à
monkey et la déforestation
donc on déforeste pour faire des pour
mettre des paniers on déforeste pour
être du soja on déforeste pour faire des
cultures vivrières pour etc
et bien c'est un tiers des émissions
planétaires donc l'agriculture c'est pas
du tout négligeable dans les émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est un sujet dont il faut absolument
s'occupait alors il faut absolument s'en
occuper
tout en sachant que par ailleurs à cause
de l'énergie les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui on la portion congrue des
revenus c'est à dire que le pib de
l'agriculture en france 2 pour fallout
cessé de 2% du pib français
donc les agriculteurs ont pas beaucoup
d'argent globalement et c'est compliqué
de leur dire faites ce qu'il faut pour
que tout ça ça disparaît cela on veut
plus en entendre parler
donc si on veut que l'agriculture
deviennent beaucoup moins émissifs en
gaz à effet de serre ça ne peut pas
reposer sur les épaules des suns
agriculteurs ça doit reposer sur un
contrat qui est plus large et qui
englobe l'essentiel de la société on
n'en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure au
moment des questions
les deux tiers des émissions planétaires
sont liées à l'énergie mais donc je le
répète
l'agriculture c'est quelque chose de
très significatif
l'agriculture est son sens et c'est ça
qui est la déforestation
alors dans les émissions de méthane qui
constitue l'essentiel de ces 20 %
d'origine agricole
on ne trouve pas que l'agriculture mais
on trouve surtout l'agriculture
ici vous avez la décomposition des
émissions mondiales de méthane par
source
alors ce que vous voyez ici c'est les
décharges lancent-ils je suis désolé
c'est en anglais encore une fois wright
badis et les rizières donc la voyant un
premier faux pas casser les rizières ça
c'est le cheptel
vous avez 1,5 milliard de vaches dans le
monde
le premier cheptel se trouve au brésil
avec 200 millions de tep si ma mémoire
est bonne c'est aussi une cause de
déforestation au brésil et donc sur le
cheptel bovin est la première cause
d'émission de méthane dans toutes celles
qui sont inventoriés ici après ici vous
avez les feux de forêt et pourquoi les
feux de forêt y mettre du méthane alors
que le métal brûle tout simplement parce
que quand vous avez des feux de forêt
vous avez debout une partie du bois qui
est chauffé par le feu dont le méthane
s'échappent
parce que le méthane se produit à ce
moment là par fractionnement des
molécules organiques sang et brûle donc
les feux de forêt produisent du méthane
ici vous avez la ventilation des beats
de charbon le méthane 6 constituant
principal du griot et donc on ventile
les mines pour éviter aux mineurs de
sauter en l'air
ici vous avez les fuites de gaz dans les
réseaux de distribution de gaz vous
savez que à paris périodiquement il ya
un immeuble qui sautent parce qu'il ya
eu une fuite de gaz qui a des fuites
heureusement l'essentiel des fuites de
gaz de fond pas sauter l'immeuble
enfin il existe quand même vous avez là
et enfin ça c'est le gaz le méthane qui
part directement dans l'air dans les
haies dans l'exploitation pétrolière
quand vous sentez du pétrole y étions un
peu de gaz qui est associé au pétrole le
méthane et il ya des endroits où on le
laisse partir dans l'air vous voyez que
sur l'ensemble des émissions de méthane
et bien les deux premières causes de
loin sont d'origine agricole
alors avec tout ce que je viens de vous
raconter vous avez ici quelque chose
d'intéressant à regarder qui sont les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
kilo de nourriture alors dans les
questions qui me sont parvenus avant
cette intervention il ya quelqu'un qui a
fait remarquer que c'était idiot de
conter par kilo et qu'il valait mieux
compter par kilos de protéines ou par
kilo d'hydrates de carbone c'est tout à
fait vrai mais vous allez voir que pour
ce que je vais vous dire maintenant ça
ne gène pas quand même ce que je
m'apprête à vous raconter et par kilo de
nourriture vous avez les émissions de
méthane quand c'est des produits animaux
notamment des ruminants donc vous vous
êtes pouf ici voilà pourquoi pas de
suite pour le compte et vous avez les
émissions de protoxyde d'azoté
donc ça c'est toujours dans les produits
animaux mais aussi dans les produits
végétaux puisque dans les produits
végétaux
vous avez du protoxyde d'azoté puisque
vous cultiver des cultures on ne voit
pas bien
et enfin le co2 c'est ce qui vient de la
mécanisation donc l'envoyer pour la
pêche par exemple bien c'est le diesel
du bateau mais pour le fromage
vous allez dire oui y'a pas de diesel
quand on fabrique le compter dans la
foulée caire vous avez tout à fait
raison
sauf que c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est le diesel de la
mécanisation
allons donc alors où en l'occurrence
vous n'êtes pas trop concernés mais
enfin dans les endroits où il ya
beaucoup de cultures végétales avait
beaucoup de passage de tracteurs et bien
ça fait énormément de co2 et par
ailleurs vous avez également le co2 de
la fabrication d en retrouver alors là
c'est pareil dans l'est dans les
appellations aoc où il ya peu d'engrais
de synthèse
cette partie là est plus faible lassé
voilà en gros comment ça se mais quand
c'est de l'emmental pas de sa voix j'ai
envie de dire vous avez quelque chose de
significatif ici ce que ce que je
voulais surtout vous faire remarquer
avec ce graphique c'est que vous voyez
que plus vous allez vers la droite c'est
d'ailleurs plus vous allez vers des gros
animaux et plus les émissions par kilo
sont importantes
or il se trouve que avec l'énergie le
sens de l'histoire a justement été de
nous emmener de la gauche vers la droite
on mangeait cinq fois moins de viande
par personne et par an en 1800 que jour
d'hui en france on mangeait
essentiellement des produits végétaux
donc on mangeait voyez des pommes de
terre du pain etc
des oignons puis on s'est mis à manger
des petits animaux
rappelez-vous deux ans écarté de sa
poule au pot puis on s'est mis à manger
des plus gros animaux des cochons et en
fait manger du boeuf leboeuf de chair
c'est quelque chose qui est une marque
des civilisations à l'énergie abondante
dans les temps anciens quand on mangé du
boeuf c'était du leem oeuvre de réformes
c'était de la vache laitière de réforme
ou bien c'était de l'animal de traits de
réforme mais enfin on élevait pas on ne
réservait pas des surfaces à des animaux
paris ce qui ne faisait rien leur
journée juste pour pouvoir les manger
derrière donc ce que vous voyez c'est
que le sens de l'histoire nous allons
mener vers de plus en plus de
consommation de gros animaux et dans un
monde où l'énergie se raréfiera eh bien
on refera une partie du chemin
dans ce sens là alors je vous ai parlé
de l'agriculture sous l' ambition
maintenant je vais vous en parlait
souvent de conséquences donc qu'est ce
qui se passe une fois que les gaz à
effet de serre de ressent dans
l'atmosphère et bien il dit reste c'est
ça le problème
le co2 qui est le principe à gaza fait
principal perdant gaz à effet de serre
que nous trouverons dans l'atmosphère à
une caractéristiques chimiques très
désagréable c'est que une fois qu'il est
dans l'atmosphère il est inaltérable
c'est à dire que tant qu'il est dans les
airs il est éternel pour que le co2
c'est pure de l'atmosphère il faut
qu'ils reviennent au contact du sol où
il va être soit absorbé par les végétaux
soit dissous dans l'océan à cause de
cette caractéristique du co2 le
changement climatique est un processus
qui n'a pas de réversibilité à l'échelle
des temps historiques
c'est à dire que le climat de l'an 2000
on ne le reverra jamais et même le
climat de l'an 2020 on est parti pour ne
plus jamais le revoir
parce qu'avec ce qu'on a déjà émis comme
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
le climat va continuer à se déformer de
toute façon pour des siècles et des
milliers d'années à venir sans qu'on ne
puisse rien y faire ce qu'on peut encore
faire c'est limiter l'ampleur du
changement et ça ça dépend de la
limitation des émissions que nous allons
occasionnées mais les émissions passées
sont déjà suffisante pour que le climat
devienne très différent de 8 50 de ce
qu'il était en 2000 alors dans les
choses qui vont se produire alors cette
part dans cette déformation du climat
est liée au fait qu'un gaz à effet de
serre est un gaz qui absorbe les
infrarouges terrestre donc la chaleur
émise par la paire on va dire qu'ils
absorbent ça avant que ça s'échappe dans
l'espace et donc il ya une espèce de
déchets de couverture qui augmente la
quantité d'énergie qui est disponible
dans le sol et les basses couches de
l'atmosphère et donc ça réchauffe
l'ensemble mais pas mais ça ne fait pas
que ça sarah d'autres effets et alors
dans les autres effets que ça
l'augmentation de cette quantité
d'énergie emporté dans la partie dans le
sol les océans et les basses couches de
l'atmosphère
c'est que ça va modifier les
précipitations a envoyé ici une carte
qui représente l'atlantique nord des
etats-unis jusqu'à la sibérie avec
l'évolution des précipitations dans un
monde qui se réchauffe pense que oui
c'est très au nord en vert et bleu les
précipitations augmente mais au pourtour
du bassin méditerranéen et le pourtour
du bassin méditerranéen dans cette
affaire
il va jusqu'à l'île de france eh bien
vous voyez que c'est plutôt une baisse
des précipitations à laquelle on doit
s'attendre avec des endroits où ça
devrait être particulièrement marqués
dont un tiens ça vous rappelle quelque
chose à cirer
est ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique
c'est que dans la région méditerranéenne
donc dans ce rectangle là et bien les
précipitations par dont l'humidité des
sols en eau va baisser de 10% par degrés
de réchauffement
donc dans un monde qui se réchauffe de 2
degrés vous vous rappelez que c'est
l'objectif de l'accord de paris de
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés est
bien l'humidité des sols dans cette
région la paire déjà 20% dans un monde
qui se réchauffe de 4° l'humidité des
sols perd 40%
dit autrement une bonne partie des
cultures que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui les pâturages que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ne serait plus
possible dans un monde à 4 degrés et
même dans un monde à deux degrés ça va
très significativement changé ici vous
avez l'europe centrale alors l'europe
centrale vous voyez que la tendance est
beaucoup moins marquée
sauf que en fait c'est la somme de deux
tendances très différentes qui est une
augmentation des précipitations et
l'humidité des sols au nord et une
diminution quand même deux des
précipitations et surtout l'humidité des
sols sur le sud de la zone
donc en france il faut malheureusement
s'attendre à ce que l'été 2010 8 et le
thé 2019 se répète de plus en plus
souvent et je pense que l'art je ne
viens pas de vous annoncer une bonne
nouvelle et non seulement il faut
s'attendre à ce que ça se répète mais il
faut s'attendre à ce que ça s'amplifie
alors ces évolutions vont notamment
avoir pour conséquence une baisse des
rendements des cultures
ici vous voyez des projections qui ont
été faites dans lesquels on imagine
c'était en gagner un rapport du giec que
ça baisse de 1 à 2 % par décennie alors
c'est pas énorme
vous allez me dire mais enfin ça coûte
voilà c'est c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est qu'ils aient marqué et
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut conjuguer
avec une autre évolution qui est la
croissance démographique qui a conduit à
une diminution très nette de la quantité
de terres cultivables par personne en
l'espace de
vous voyez un peu moins de 65 ans il y
avait 1 5 hectares cultivables par
personne en 1960 en moyenne mondiale
on est aujourd'hui à 0,7 et on arrive à
nourrir tout le monde parce que c'est
0,7 sont shootés aux combustibles
fossiles tracteurs et engrais alors que
là ce n'était pas le cas mais quand tu
es combustibles fossiles vont commencer
à faire défaut et que ça sera plus
difficile d'avoir des tracteurs et des
engrais est bien bien évidemment on va
avoir un énorme problème
d'approvisionnement agricole sur ce
graphique qui a été publiée par le giec
il y a maintenant un an plus ou moins
qu'elle est plus ou moins six mois on
peut plus vous avez un certain nombre de
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
qui sont évoqués alors là dedans il y en
a deux qui vous concerne directement il
ya l'érosion des sols vous avec le
changement climatique aggrave l'érosion
des sols et c'est normal parce que vous
avez des précipitations intenses qui
deviennent plus fréquentes sa érode les
sols surtout si ça tombe sur des sols
qui par ailleurs ne reçoit pas l'appui
très souvent et puis vous avez alors ici
c'est les cultures tropicales ça vous
concerne pas trop mais ce que vous voyez
là c'est que à cause de l'augmentation
des sécheresses et d'autres pressions
vous allez avoir sur les cultures les
ravageurs parce que les petites bêtes se
déplace plus vite que gross
vous avez par exemple des champignons
qui se met à remonter vers le nord dans
l'est alors ça vous concerne pas vous
directement mais chez les champenois
vous avez aujourd'hui du bild ou alors
qu'il ya 30 ou 40 ans il en avait pas
donc vous avez de la dépression sur la
végétation à la fois j'ai envie de dire
naturel et y cultiver qui fait que le
giec dit que à partir de 2,5 degrés ou
trois degrés
le code violet lassé des conséquences
qui sont généralisés irréversible vous
allez avoir une insécurité alimentaire
qui va devenir généralisée irréversibles
sur terre alors la sécurité alimentaire
généralisée et irréversible vous savez
comme moi est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que ça devient le bazar
partout parce que quand les gens n'ont
plus de quoi manger
en général ils deviennent pas
sympathique alors si on veut éviter ce
genre de plaisanterie et je vais finir
par ça vous avez ici un graphique qui
vous donne le cahier des charges
de ce que ça signifie de te dire j'ai
envie de dire les deux degrés dont tout
le monde parle en ce moment ce graphique
il vous dit quelque chose de très simple
il vous dit que c'est une superposition
de simulation mais vous voyez que ça
suis embrouillé droite et donc la
manière dont il faut le comprendre est
assez simple ça vous dit qu en fonction
de la quantité totale de co2 qu'on va
mettre dans l'atmosphère qui est gradué
ici donc mille milliards de tonnes de
mille milliards de tonnes et c est bien
la température entre l'ère
préindustrielle et 2100 se réchauffera
d'un certain nombre de degrés dit
autrement je vous donne la quantité
totale de co2 qu'on aimait entre l'ère
préindustrielle et 2100 et ça suffit
quelle que soit la façon dont on ora
émises
ça suffit pour vous dire bah voilà entre
l'ère préindustrielle et 2100 le climat
va se réchauffer de temps alors tout ça
peut paraître un peu abstrait passons à
l'application concrète à fin 2010 8
l'humanité avait déjà vie dans
l'atmosphère un peu plus de 2000
milliards de tonnes de co2 et donc ce
que ça veut dire c'est que de toute
façon les 1,5 degré on va les passer à
un moment ou un autre
d'ici à 2100 les 1,5 degré on les
passera et inversement si on veut tenir
les deux degrés ça veut dire qu'on doit
limiter les émissions planétaires cumulé
à 3000 milliards de tonnes dont 2200 ont
déjà été émises ce qui veut dire en
pratique et c'est de là que vous voyez
les grandes déclarations qui sont faites
sur la baisse des émissions etc
ça veut dire que les émissions
planétaires doivent être divisées par
trois d'ici à ce que mes enfants et mon
âge
pour dire les choses de façon
extrêmement simple donc d'ici à 2050
eh bien il faut que les émissions
planétaires soit divisé par trois et en
france ça veut dire en gros les diviser
par cinq à six si on est sur un régime
communiste où chacun arrive à zéro donc
dans cette histoire là bien évidemment
il va falloir s'attaquer aux voitures et
aux bâtiments mais ça suffira pas il
faudra aussi s'attaquer aux vaches
je pense que nous allons avoir une
discussion intéressante sur la façon de
faire ça voilà j'ai fini cette première
partie est donc maintenant je vous
propose de passer aux questions merci
beaucoup
alors j'ai vu qu emmanuelle avait déjà
envoyé une question à part le google
forme et il a réagi aussi en disant que
les chiffres des graphiques sont en fait
issu de la méthode de l'analyse de cycle
de vie qui n'est pas adapté à
l'agriculture emmanuel est que toi tu
souhaites prendre la parole pour
t'expliquer et poser la question oui ou
à moins que j'en à vous voulez répondre
avant non je veux bien comprendre la
question oui oui oui
ce qui me gêne ce qui me gêne beaucoup
dans les comparaisons c'est con con des
comparaisons vous avez fait c'est qu'on
compare du co2 20 des gaz à effet de
serre fossiles avec d'aiguèze d'origine
biogénique qui font partie d'un cycle
donc je trouve que la méthode ne fait
pas partie d'un cycle
le métal n'a pas depuis le maître le
méthane se décompose bien non il me met
dix ans pour se décomposer le méthane
ben oui mais ce n'est pas une semaine
oui mais dix ans dix ans à effectif un
cheptel constants on peut pas en
principe ça marche pas comme ça en fait
le mec ce qu'il faut regarder
quand vous regardez un gaz à effet de
serre il faut à la fois regarder sa
durée de vie et sa capacité d'absorption
des infrarouges
or le métal a une capacité instantanée
dab sortir des infrarouges qui est de
l'ordre de
102 100 fois celle du co2 donc si vous
composez ça avec le fait
qu'effectivement ça durait dix est plus
courte que celle du co2 mais néanmoins
de 10 ans vous avez quand même un effet
réchauffant qui est considérablement
plus fort que celui du co2 donc ce qui
se passe avec le carbone c'est que le
carbone passe dans l'herbe donc le co2
est soustrait de l'atmosphère pour
passer dans l'herbe
là-dessus la vaches mangent de l'herbe
et une partie de ce carbone ressort de
lavage sous forme de méthane
donc vous avez soustrait du co2
l'atmosphère vous lui avez mis à la
place du méthane et ça malheureusement
ce n'est pas ainsi que le fermer oui
j'entends bien mais un cheptel constant
où il n'ya pas accroissement c'est à
dire qu'il ya bien une émission et il ya
une absorption
donc si on fait pas évoluer le cheptel
et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est le cas
en france parce que le cheptel bovin
notamment a plutôt tendance à régresser
on ne peut pas considérer que les vaches
sont participe à l'accroissement des gaz
à effet de serre s'ils avaient déjà fait
quoi maintenant elle participe aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre clair
que tous les ans les vaches maigres dans
l'atmosphère du méthane et elle le met
en plus des sources naturelles
il ya toujours eu un cycle naturel du
méthane sur terre mais on peut très
facilement montré à partir de carottage
que la concentration en méthane
c'est vise à augmenter de manière très
significative à partir de la révolution
agricole
donc les vaches participe à
l'accroissement de la concentration en
méthane
malheureusement c'est je ne comprends
pas comment ça peut marcher
comment est-ce que vous ouvrez des
robinets les uns derrière les autres
donc vous ouvrez un robinet un premier
robinet qui s'appelle la première vache
après un deuxième robinet qui s'appelle
la deuxième manche après etc
il ya de plus en plus de vaches dans le
monde donc le robinet arrête pas
d'augmenter les batinses et là c'est là
qu'on n'est pas d'accord c'est pas vrai
je moi je pour la france le cheptel
diminue du web et de tout mais pas dire
que vous pouvez pas dire que la vache
supplémentaires et celle qui est crédité
de la totalité de l'accroissement en
fait ce qui quand vous ouvrez un robinet
supplémentaires dans une baignoire avec
la baignoire déborde
c'est la faute du dernier robinet que
vous avez ouvert où c'est la faute du
premier ben justement justement en
france on n'ouvre pas de robinet on a
plutôt amélioré l'atmosphère se brasse
le problème des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est que la durée de brassage
de l'atmosphère est de l'ordre de
l'année donc pour un gaz qui a une durée
de vie dans la
faire de dix ans le lieu d émission n'a
aucune espèce d'importance donc que le
méthane soit émis en france en inde ou
au brésil ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance on paye quand même pour les
autres si là pour le coup je sais pas si
on paye pour les autres à ce stade là
pour le moment où je vous parle de
physique et donc la physique se dit la
physique vous dit que le lieu d émission
n'a strictement aucune espèce
d'importance c'est comme ça et c'est
également vrai pour le co2 c'est bien
pour ça dure est que c'est légitime de
faire des analyses dans lesquels on
agrège des émissions qui ont lieu
partout dans le monde ce qui serait
totalement invalide
si vous aviez des sources qui sont
locales avec des effets locales par
exemple l'empreinte eau est quelque
chose qui de mon point de vue est
beaucoup plus discutable parce que
additionner un litre d'eau en norvège et
un litre d'eau au sahel
je vois pas de tapage eux j'en vois pas
vraiment la logique par contre en ce qui
concerne les émissions c'est le même
déversoir c'est-à-dire l'atmosphère dans
lequel se retrouvent toutes les
émissions planétaires et comme je vous
le disais ça se brasse vous pourriez pas
tenir ce raisonnement pour l'ozone par
exemple qui est un gaz qui émis dans
l'atmosphère avec une durée de vie très
courte donc les émissions d'ozone qui
ont lieu en france en berne
essentiellement les français ça
enquiquine extrêmement peu les manchots
de l'antarctique
par contre en ce qui concerne les gaz à
effet de serre ça marche pas comme ça
un mince et zoologique aux agents me
suis rendu compte tout ce qui tout ce
qui était dit partout dans le monde
arrive dans la même atmosphère et donc
vous avez une homogénéisation de ceux de
ceux qui s'y met après il faut bien voir
que la constance des émissions ne
garantit pas pour autant l'innocuité des
émissions l'innocuité des émissions vous
l'avez à partir du moment où les
émissions constante ne sont pas
supérieurs ou puis donc à partir du
moment où alors le puits est
effectivement en ce qui concerne le
méthane il et atmosphérique 1 le méthane
il est dégradé par des radicaux
hydroxyles dans l'atmosphère mais ces
radicaux hydroxyles sont capables des
purées une certaine quantité de méthane
qui arrivent par an et si vous en mettez
plus et bien le surplus s'accumulent
donc en ce qui concerne le méthane c'est
pas la constance des émissions qui est
importante en face et c'est un élément
d'appréciation
mais ce qui est vraiment important c'est
comme pour le co2 il faut qu'à un moment
les émissions redeviennent inférieur à
ce que le puits naturels est capable de
déployer ses cinq buts
je crois que là la question du
changement climatique elle est difficile
à appréhender dans le sens où on a
l'impression que si chez nous les choses
se passent bien il y aura pas de
conséquence dans ces îles ce sont des
phénomènes qui sont colossaux donc c'est
pas parce qu'en france on va limiter le
nombre de verges par exploitation où on
ne remontera pas le super que le cheptel
qui existe n'est pas né mais très peu de
de méthane et de co2 et j'ai oublié de
donner quelques règles au niveau de l'
échange qui est en fait il ya des
personnes qui m'ont envoyé en avance des
questions donc effectivement emmanuel et
pour gérer un peu parce que nous sommes
120 l'a donc là ce que je vous propose
c'est déjà peut-être balayé les
questions qui ont été envoyés en amont
et ensuite on verra si nous avons temple
pour comment dire abordé d'autres
questions
jean marc est ce que vous êtes d'accord
comme ça
oui très bien alors j'ai fait un
classement en fait et des questions qui
sont commentées et vous pouvez toujours
à passer vos questions à travers le 4e
j'ai des collègues qui vont m'aider à
aller à les transférer sur sur un un
document que je consulte en même temps
donc j'ai mis en avant surtout les
questions qui ont été posées par des
agriculteurs parce qu'il ya d'autres
questions qui ont été également posées
par des techniciens et des conseillers
agricoles mais j'ai mis la priorité sur
les agriculteurs parce que nous avons
organisée surtout cette webconférence à
leur destination
alors il ya plusieurs questions qui
concernent la démission donc de carbone
et de méthane où il y avait la question
justement de d'emmanuel bien de poser et
il y avait une question aussi clés liés
à l'émission de carbone par rapport aux
deux pôles terrestres
donc ça concerne peut-être aussi la
gestion des prêts ville retournement des
prairies et c'est quoi c'est sylvain qui
demandaient des agriculteurs dans le
doubs qui demandait est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui arrêter de sortir du carbone
du sous-sol terrestre lors du carbone
sous forme d'énergie fossile ou du
carbone dans les sols agricoles
pourquoi ce que c'est c'est narbonne
dans les seuls à l'école oui la perte
oui on la perte de carbone des sols
agricoles en fait elle est due à
plusieurs à plusieurs processus au
moment où les sols agricoles sont formés
j'ai envie de dire essentiellement en
général en prenant sur la forêt
historiquement dans les sols agricoles
étaient des sols couverts de forêts par
exemple en europe en europe du nord en
l'an mil le couvert forestier c'était 80
% de la surface du territoire conduit ça
doit être pourquoi 20%
donc en fait en france comme en europe
les régions qu'on a laissé à la forêt
sont essentiellement des régions qui
sont pas commodes pour l'agriculture des
régions de montagne ou bien des régions
vraiment il poussait à 3 van der pour
les motos sont là comme dans 80 cantons
quand on coupe la forêt en fait le sol
va perdre du carbone parce que sous
terre il y avait toute la masse de
carbone des racines qui vont lentement
ce minéralisées donc ça c'est une
première source d'émissions de carbone
par les sols et ensuite quand on laboure
les sols ce qu'on fait en général pour
enfouir ce qui pousse dessus parce que
c'est une forme de désherbage pratique
j'ai envie de dire c'est également une
forme de travail du sol qui est pratique
dans les grandes cultures pour être sûr
que les graines qu'on aura semé
s'enfonce bien
eh bien on exposé à l'air
le les racines et une partie des
bestioles qui a dans sous terre et du
coup ça va également se décomposer c'est
à dire se minéraliser et de cette
manière là le car le sol perdu carbone
donc en fait pour conserver le carbone
dans les sols
il faut faire les opérations j'ai envie
de dire inverse de celle qu'on a fait
historiquement il faut planter des
arbres donc des haies ou d'effacer
foresterie est pareil avec par ailleurs
la boad moins possible ou arrêtez de la
borie voilà c'est ça le sait ça j'ai
envie de dire les deux grandes
opérations qui permettent de remettre du
carbone dans le sol
il ya eu une technique dans les grandes
cultures qui s'appelle maintenant le
semis sous couvert c'est à dire qu'on
laisse pousser des plantes des cultures
intermédiaires sur les sols quand on n'a
pas de culture à vocation alimentaire et
au moment où on s'aime
alors c'est évidemment un truc qui fait
hurler les gens qui n'aiment pas ça on
passe un grand coup de désherbant au
lieu de labourer vocale en couple il
faut date
et puis là dessus on se contente de
passer derrière avec une averse pour
semer enfin on gratte un peu on sème et
ça permet évidemment pardon ça permet
d'éviter de labour donc ça a une vertu
sur le carbone qui est non négligeable
avec ce genre de technique oui c'est ce
sont des techniques qui sont reconnus
ici au niveau des agriculteurs notamment
les oiseaux qui travaillent avec nous
avons l'association d'encoder des
agriculteurs qui pratiquent
l'agriculture de conservation des sols à
la csc partie d'ailleurs il ya françois
momboisse et de france en système
justement bac et coûteux de conservation
des sols
c'est le new labour c'est la couverture
du stock permanent et un système de
rotation donc les cultures et lui il
disait qu'il faudrait en fait ces
pratiques agricoles c'est une pratique
qui permet justement de de pouvoir
atténuer les effets
du climat et il aimerait savoir comment
augmenter plus ces surfaces qui sont pas
aujourd'hui donc que majoritaire et je
suis pas sûr que jean marc question qui
est quand même très spécifiques
après on va rentrer dans va rentrer dans
des considérations disent en général des
considérations économiques
c'est yahia je veux dire les
agriculteurs sont comme tout le monde
des gens qui doivent avoir un compte
d'exploitation et en général c'est un
des premiers déterminant de ce qu'ils
vont faire
donc il ya j'ai pas là j'ai pas le jeu
ne prétend pas avoir déjà ça va beaucoup
dépendre de l'équation
après il ya beaucoup de gens par exemple
aussi qu'ils utilisaient culture atfal
ya plus en plus de gens qui utilisent
maintenant les cultures intermédiaires
pour faire de la méthanisation
selon vous avez un méthaniseur ou pas
pas de chez vous ça change l'équation
économique par un congrès donc c'est
j'ai envie de dire oui je sais que ça
existe mais c'est hier comment favoriser
sa de manière spécifique demanderait de
ma part une ataxie que j'ai jamais faite
alors justement sur la question des
cultures énergétiques ou des cultures
qui permet d'alimenter des méthaniseurs
parce que nous avons vous étiez pas en
parler
j'ai mon employeur et d'un qui m'ont
président national de l'association
femmes et qui est également donc un
agriculteur qui fait de la méthanisation
est donc est ce que en termes de bilan
carbone
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire aux cultures
énergétiques alors je suis pas sûr
d'avoir compris la question est ce qu'on
peut dire ou es ce qu'est ce que le
puisque la méthanisation permet d'éviter
plus de combustibles fossiles que les
combustibles fossiles utilisés pour
culte pour produire les cultures
intermédiaires c'est ça non en fait dans
ma question il ya oui il peut y avoir
des seins mais il ya le fait ou
qu'est-ce que ça fait par exemple
de cultiver de cultiver d'avoir des
cultures notamment les méthaniseurs ça
dépend beaucoup de la façon dont on a en
fait la culture énergétique
d'une manière générale s'inscrivent dans
un schéma beaucoup plus large de
concurrence d'usagé des sols
on va dire que le sol qui est disponible
en quantité limitée
il peut être destinées à des usages
suivants on peut le destinés à
l'alimentation directes ou indirectes
c'est-à-dire l'alimentation des hommes
ou l'alimentation du bétail
franck des niveaux largement on peut le
destiner à dubois ya des services
écosystémiques père ce qu'il ya sur le
sol et on peut être destinées à des
infrastructures et dans le les cultures
intermédiaires où les cultures
énergétiques pardon elles s'inscrivent
dans le cadre de cette grande de cet
arbitrage alors il se trouve qu'en ce
moment si on regarde la totalité de ce
conte des soins sociaux qui sont
exprimés dans ces domaines là on a la
foi des gens qui souhaitent que on est
plus de surfaces qui sont dévolus à la
biodiversité qui est plus d'endroits où
en fiche la paix ce qui se passe quoi
qu'il se passe donc ça évidemment c'est
pas disponible pour des cultures
énergétiques parce que si c'est
disponible pour caen 6 la paix aux
espèces vivantes assez disponible pour
yad autres je dis pas que c'est une
mauvaise idée
je dis que c'est vous avez des gens qui
réclament ça pour du matériau donc du
bois d'oeuvre à ce moment alors le bois
d'oeuvre se marient éventuellement avec
les cultures énergétiques dans la mesure
où une partie des rémanents
dans la sylviculture peut être utilisé
pour faire de l'énergie mais bon vous
avez des gens qui réclament que
l'agriculture soit moins intensive à ce
moment ça veut dire que la production
identique elle a besoin de plus de
surface là dedans vous avez des gens qui
réclament une agriculture moins
intensive avec le même type
d'alimentation et d'autres qui réclament
une alimentation différente parce que il
accepte que ce soit comme ça que j'ai
envie de dire traduisent le fait que
l'agriculture est moins intensive vous
avez des gens qui avec l'âme cette
surface pour faire des lotissements
pavillonnaires
voilà donc on a on a un j'ai envie de
dire le répondre à la question est ce
qu'il faut faire des cultures à vocation
énergétique
en fait c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'il y paraît si on regarde de
l'équation prise dans son dans son
ensemble à titre personnel
moi j'ai envie de dire que la
méthanisation si on en fait le premier
usage auquel ça doit être réservé c'est
la substitution des carburants fossiles
qui sont utilisés par les agriculteurs
eux-mêmes ou éventuellement par des
services publics dans le monde rural
le transport scolaire les transports en
commun etc
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça confère
aujourd'hui les deux premiers usages de
la métallisation c'est de la production
électrique
alors là pour le coup de mon point de
vue ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt
soit la production électrique en france
et déjà décarbonés dont je vois pas
pourquoi on mobiliserait du sol pour
remplacer la production décarbonée qui
est déjà là énormément le nucléaire pour
moi ça sera aucun intérêt ça peut être
intéressant pour l'agriculteur dans le
système des aides qui existent
aujourd'hui mais du point de vue du pays
pour moi ça n'a aucun intérêt
et la deuxième chose qui est beaucoup
fait aujourd'hui c'est injecter le gaz
dans le réseau ce qui veut dire que ce
gaz participera pour partie à chauffer
enfin alimenter des chaudières à gaz
alors que ces mêmes chaudière à gaz on
pourrait les remplacer par des pompes à
chaleur et d'isolation donc la
méthanisation aujourd'hui si je replace
ça dans un système global
j'y suis favorable sous réserve que le
premier usage soit un usage de
substitution des carburants fossiles et
non pas un usage de substitution
d'électricité décarbonée
voire même un usage d'injection dans le
réseau bon qui équipe déjà mieux que
d'en faire d'électricité mais qui
pourraient être évités et là il faut
raisonner économie ces records cancan de
la puissance publique mais un million
d'euros quelque part est-ce que c'est
mieux de le mettre dans une aide pour
que les gens remplacent leur chaudière à
gaz par des pompes à chaleur est à ce
moment ça évite du gaz possible sans
avoir besoin de faire de méthanisation
ou est-ce que c'est mieux de le mettre
dans la méthanisation
voilà après il ya une deuxième question
derrière qui est si l'agriculteur a
besoin de revenus est ce que c'est en
lui faisant faire de la méthanisation
que c'est la meilleure manière de
l'aider ce qui est un autre sujet donc
voilà donc ça ferait pour c'est un peu
longue mais c'est juste pour dire que
c'est toujours très difficile et vous
savez vieux coin dans le domaine
agricole de détacher une question de
tout le reste du système
oui ils sont confrontés au quotidien
alors pour continuer sur les les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre j'ai
une question qui est pliée donc pas ce
qui s'y sont cette région nous sommes en
systèmes de prairies naturelles dont des
prêts permanents qui sont pas retournés
au moins pendant cinq ans et donc il ya
un agriculteur qui demandent où on peut
du coup calculer des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre oublier cette pratique
spécifique d'élevage en systèmes de
prairies naturelles et comment on veut
on peut
comment dire atténuer les effets des
changements climatiques
hormis le fait d'arrêter l'élevage alors
le canton à pau pour ce canton à
regarder la question de l'élevage
dans le think tank là dans le cube j
project en fait on n'a pas du tout dit
qu'il fallait arrêter desvages ce qu'on
pense que je vois que la question a été
posée aussi là dans le jeu discutant le
fils de 10 ans la voilà quelles
propositions faites vous pour
l'agriculture ces pressions de l'élevage
alors la réponse est non pourquoi est-ce
que la réponse est non d'abord parce que
le jour où il y aura plus de
fertilisants azotés venant de
l'industrie pétrochimique
il faudra bien disposer toujours de
fertilisants et a priori les déjections
des animaux
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
marche assez bien la deuxième raison
pour laquelle ces noms c'est que il ya
un certain nombre de zones en france
notamment les zones de montagne or le
jura c'est pas dire que ça fait partie
des zones de montagne où l'activité
agricole la plus évidente c'est
l'élevage c'est moins d'y faire des
champs de blé
la troisième raison pour laquelle on
pense que ces noms c'est que le la qu'en
dire on peut très bien conjuguer une
baisse significative du cheptel avec une
augmentation de la rémunération des
agriculteurs alors pour ça il faut des
éleveurs alors pour ça il faut faire un
truc qui est une hérésie évidemment dans
le monde moderne mais enfin que le monde
agricole connaît quand même bien qu'ils
s'appellent l'encadrement des prix donc
ce que le système auquel on pense est un
système qui ressemble à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans le monde des énergies
renouvelables qui s'appelle des prix
garantis dans le monde des énergies
renouvelables le producteur éolien vous
dis bon d'électricité coûte plus cher
que l'électricité du réseau
donc si vous voulez que je fasse de
l'éolien vous allez me garantir que vous
mâche et raymond d'électricité au moins
temps donc si j'avais le prix de marché
est supérieure à temps et bien la
garantie ne joue pas par contre si le
prix de marché est inférieure à temps va
vous payer la différence
et alors ce qu'on se dit c'est qu'on
pourrait faire quelque chose d'identique
dans le monde de l'élevage avec
l'équivalent du caractère renouvelable
dans le bond de les nerfs
qui ça serait à cahier des charges dit
autrement on demanderait aux éleveurs de
respecter un cahier des charges
permettant de garantir la plus basse
empreinte carbone possible en échange de
quoi il y aurait un prix garanti
alors là où ses comptes et est déjà
assez proche d'un système comme ça c'est
à dire qu' il n'y a pas de ceci il n'y a
pas de cela les vaches sont dehors elle
son pâturage et le mange du point en
échange de quoi le litre de lait est
payé plus cher que si on le vendait à
l'acte elle pour finir chez carrefour
voilà l'idée ce serait de renforcer ce
système là et avec un avantage
supplémentaire nous semble-t-il c'est
que tant qu'on n'a pas changé les règles
du commerce mondial
tout ce qui est de l'ordre du cahier des
charges et du label c'est une protection
contre les importations c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne peut pas faire de comté
ailleurs canton ailleurs que dans jeux
interdits
donc je peux pas faire du comté en
angleterre ou encore d'âge ou en pologne
ou en chine
et dire c'est du comté n'a pas le droit
voilà donc le ce à quoi on pense c'est
quelque chose de cette nature c'est à
dire à vous alors évidemment la
conséquence pratique c'est que
l'essentiel du cheptel qui disparaît
dans un dans un système comme ça c'est
le cheptel en stabulation c'est le
cheptel qui noyaient l'ensilage et qui
voilà qui vaut le pâturage une fois une
fois tous les 36 du mois mai mais c'est
un peu à ça que c'est un peu à ça
compense si je réponds à la question est
en effet c'est aussi des systèmes qui
existent déjà il ya déjà un cahier des
charges
par contre dans le moment je pense pas
enfin carbone soit un peu dedans je dis
peut-être des bêtises il ya des
producteurs de comté qui me connaissent
aussi un cahier des charges qui
garantissent en fait ce qu'il faut c'est
que le cahier des charges garantissant
empreinte carbone c'est à dire autrement
il s'agit pas de la calculer
exploitation par exploitation
il s'agit de donner un cahier des
charges en disant ben voilà
vous retournez pas les prairies vous
faites ceci vous faites cela vous mettez
au moins tant de temps de les parcelles
vous mettez au moins tant de et par
parent seul enfin des trucs de cette
nature et en échange de quoi je vous
achète le litre de lait 40 50 60 70 80
90 centimes au moins c'est un système
comme ça avant qu'ali qu'il faut être
capable de mettre en place et en moyenne
ça fera le job ça sera pas la peine
derrière de calculer exploitation par
exploitation
c'est celle avantages des processus qui
sont raisonnablement homogène sur tous
les producteurs de compte et
fonctionnent de la même manière ils ont
tous des vaches s'ils ont tous des
pâturages il traite tous leurs matchs et
ils font tous le comté de la même
manière donc quand on a des processus
assez homogène comme ça en fait on n'est
pas obligé d'aller faire des calculs
dans des exploitations aux prises une
par une
en même temps c'est un peu l'intention
des éleveurs que je travaille un peu de
continuer à améliorer leur système est
donc de faire vraiment d'aller je ne
focalise plus ferme parce que même s'ils
respectent le même cahier des charges
il ya des pratiques qui peuvent dans la
limite de payer des charges variés
preview nous travaillons avec un groupe
qui s'appelle jean dauzère d'avenir qui
regroupe une dizaine d'exploitations
à l'intérieur on peut avoir des niveaux
par exemple d'achat d'animaux
élémentaires qui a un qui peut varier
d'une exploitation à goutte pour qui
cherche toujours à améliorer quand même
dans leurs marges alors oui mais ça ce
que je dis pas que c'est interdit
je dis juste que si on veut un système
raisonnablement simple le système le
plus simple
celui qui demande le moins deux qui va
demander le moins de temps
à denver c'est quand même un système de
type cahier des charges oui il ya une
remarque est dit que le mit de prix
minimaux garantis par rapport à cahier
des charges c'est un système de commerce
équitable dans les systèmes ici dans le
système conté ici en fait ce sont les
organisations de producteurs qui qui qui
donc suivre se payer des charges et
garantit le maintien d'un prix par
rapport voté mais dans le dans l'idée de
vous parler d'un par rapport au simple
on moi j'ai l'impression qu'on voit
aussi au delà de ça c'est à dire qu'il
s'agit aussi d'une contractualisation
par rapport à bas soit des pouvoirs
publics ne soit avec des citoyens
mais bien sûr pourquoi ce prix là soit
garanti mais c'est dans la file de ce
que j ai tout à leurs cirque aujourd'hui
on paye on paye la nourriture très peu
cher ce qui permet par ailleurs
d'acheter des chaussettes des cahiers
des ordinateurs des meubles des machins
et c'est le mot de sobriété et que tout
le monde maintenant à présent à l'esprit
la contrepartie économique de cette
sobriété c'est que le prix de n'importe
quoi augmentera et donc on fera
nécessairement des arbitrages et si on
veut que les la production de ce qu'on
conserve se fasse dans des conditions
qui soient environnementalement plus
satisfaisante en terme de traduction
économique ça voudra dire nécessairement
que les prix unitaires vous mentez c'est
à dire oui mais ça veut dire que les
changements nous là on est avec des
brouettes en soi mais effectivement
c'est déjà difficile de réfléchir aux
changements à faire par rapport à
larguer l'organisation décrit des
apports à la 38ème des entreprises et là
il ya en fait quatre ans quelque sorte
aussi un changement en termes de modes
de consommation où je voudrais que les
consommateurs
la nourriture qu'on a c'est alors une
question justement lié en pole et les
appellations d'origine contrôlée et
protégé qu'ils font quand même qu'il ya
des territoires qui se spécialise et
donc par rapport à cette spécialisation
qui implique aussi par des transports
dans une région comme les spécialités
production il faut aussi le transporter
ailleurs donc un cahier des charges la
protection par rapport à une appellation
d'origine oui mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'on va aussi vers une spécialisation
du territoire je suis pas sûr de
comprendre la question se dire que vous
vous dites les ça sera plus difficile de
transporter partout dans le monde ce
qu'on produit aussi de l'énergie donc
pas ce que vont tous les comptes est
fabriqué en boucle en franche comté ne
pourrait pas être consommés en franche
comté pour ça on est d'accord
cela étant le dans un monde où l'énergie
devient moins disponibles en fait ce qui
va se passer c'est que la circulation
des marchandises deviendra un peu plus
difficile mais ça sera d'autant plus
vrai que les marchandises valent pas
cher par kilo de poids donc les à
l'époque où le ou l'énergie abondante
n'existait pas il y avait du commerce
international mais s'était limité à des
denrées qui valait très cher par unité
de poids donc c'était des pierres
précieuses de la soie du sel le sel
était un truc qui valait très cher par
unité de poids mais on transportait pas
des troncs d'arbres tout autour de la
terre et on transportait même pas des
céréales tout autour de la terre on
avait quelques cas de figure très
particulier les céréales du nil qui
allait jusqu'à rome voilà mais c'est
cesser sinon ça n'existait pas et donc
c'est à partir du moment où on s'est mis
à avoir de l'énergie abondante et des
transports qui valaient rien que l'on
s'est mis à transporter tout et
n'importe quoi sur des milliers de
kilomètres
mais avant ça n'existait pas cela étant
le fromage était quand même quelque
chose qui se transportait même avant est
en fait le fromage a précisément été
fabriqué pour pouvoir facilement
transporté de l'aide à dire une meule
une meule de comté vous la voulez vous
l'apprendre d assez facilement d'un bout
à l'autre de la france beaucoup plus
facilement que la quantité de lave
équivalente
oui moins d'énergie pour la conservation
à la il ya une question justement sur
bâtiments en termes de changements de
consommation c'est comment concilier par
exemple le fait manger moins de viande
parce que c'est aussi une inquiétude des
éleveurs tout en conservant donc la
capacité des bébés c'est exactement ce
que j'ai tout à l'heure c'est le prix
minimum garanti
en gros si on mange moins nous vivrons
alors je vais vous le dire d'ailleurs
encore plus encore plus illustré le
système dans lequel les verts ne perd
pas est un système dans lequel on divise
le cheptel par deux on augmente les prix
par trois ans sortie de ferme les gens
dépenseront la même quantité d'argent
pour la pourra manger moins et la seule
condition à la caste acceptable pour le
consommateur final c'est qu'ils
ressentent une augmentation de qualité
dans la sphère d'où le fait que ça doit
nécessairement aller avec des cahiers
des charges qui sont considérés comme
étant entre guillemets bénéfique à la
fois à l'environnement et aux
consommateurs
le seul système dans lequel sa peau
simple s'inclure de façon
j'ai envie de dire non non perdante pour
l'éleveur est un système de cette nature
est en fait vous voyez bien que les
circuits courts qui sont en train de se
mettre en place en ce moment les gens
qui vendent directement sur les marchés
etc
ça participe exactement de cette
équation économique dire que c'est des
systèmes dans lesquels en général le
prix au kilo que l'éleveur récupère est
un prix supérieur à ce qu'il a ce qui
l'aurait s'ils vendaient à des
intermédiaires
oui bon je pense que je vais pas faire
un débat ici c'est pas le lieu
mais c'est pas une question simplement
des bois d'achat mais je garde cette
question ou des débats après dans nos
associations
il ya j'ai une question pour compléter
sa c'est alors je ne sais pas si on peut
répondre à ça quel est le niveau de
pratique
alors j'en ai déjà parlé un peu peur en
fait l'élevage il a besoin la production
végétale pour commencer
donc il ya un premier niveau de
vulnérabilité c'est qu'il faut pas que y
ait des prairies sèches tous les ans
donc vous avez déjà vu en 2018 et 2019
qu'il y avait eu des épisodes très très
sec et très chaud
alors malheureusement ces épisodes là
vont se répéter et devenir plus intense
c'est à dire qu'on aura de plus en plus
d'été chaud et sec avec des périodes en
de la végétation
malheureusement c'est parti alors
aujourd'hui tant que c'est pas trop
violent et qu'on a des camions qui
peuvent transporter le foin d'une région
à une autre
c'est pas encore trop méchant même si de
temps en temps il ya des gens qui sont
obligés d'abattre une partie de leur
cheptel
mais c'est quelque chose malheureusement
qui va qui va s'amplifier il n'y a pas
grand chose à faire contre ça au sens de
on peut pas l'éviter
comme je disais tout à l'heure le coup
est parti alors plus exactement - on
s'occupera tone et errements du
changement climatique puisque c'est un
phénomène planétaire
essart boucle sur la question qui était
posée tout à l'heure qui est ce que
c'est aux français de s'occuper des
malheurs du monde
non c'est pas aux français de s'occuper
des malheurs du monde c'est à tout le
monde de contribuer à ce que le monde ne
soit pas trop malheureux donc ça marche
dans sa marche dans l'autre sens c'est à
dire que d'un monde qui est qu'ils
baissent fortement ses émissions
c'est un monde dans lequel chacun fait
sa part on ne peut pas imaginer que
c'est juste les autres qui vont s'en
occuper mais comme le climat de demain
il va être aussi dépendant de ce que
feront la totalité des autres êtres
humains sur terre
il faut se préparer comme si
malheureusement les choses n'allaient
pas très bien se passer sur le plan
d'évolution climatique
et ça ça veut dire effectivement à une
production végétale qui va souffrir de
plus en plus je vous entend plus
excusez-moi j'ai et monique oui je
disais que il ya aussi une remarque par
rapport au fait qu'on parle beaucoup de
la consommation de la viande mais il ya
une question qui dit mais est-ce que
c'est du même ordre le lait avec ton est
ce qu'on consomme des moissons moins de
fromage et du moins ceux moins de lait
et du pain spécialiste de la
consommation de lait malheureusement
j'aurais dû réviser mes fiches là dessus
et je ne suis pas capable de vous dire
quelle est la part du lait qui part en
lait à boire
on ya ourthe en fromage à pâte dure en
fromage à pâte molle et c'est donc comme
je n'ai pas cette information
malheureusement je suis pas capable de
ça oui globalement s'il ya moins de
cheptel il ya moins de lait mais je suis
pas capable de vous dire sur quel type
de consommation on peut imaginer que ça
s'arrêterait en premier je ne sais pas
si le premier à souffrir c'est les
producteurs de comté ou c'est dan ne
sais pas j'espère alors j'ai une
question d'un jeune à l'école juste pour
compléter cette réponse en général la
lecture de l'histoire est très
instructive c'est à dire si ce que je
pense le comté est plus ancien que le
yaourt chez tout le monde
la logique voudrait que dans l'autre
sens c'est ce qui est arrivé en dernier
qui partent en premier
d'accord alors donc que le comté a
encore de beaux jours devant lui parce
que ça fait quand même très longtemps
qu'il existait il ya un jeune
agriculteur qui demande par rapport à la
meilleure alternative possible parce que
c'est mieux de de labourer où c'est
mieux d'utiliser le glyphosate
rapport à un enterrement en termes
d'émissions peut-être de carbone c'est
malheureusement mieux l'utiliser du
glyphosate en terme environnemental je
ne suis pas suffisamment spécialiste de
l'étude des effets indirects du
glyphosate pour répondre je crois que je
vais je suis en train de brisbane soleil
dans les prairies il semble que le il
semble que le problème ce que se pose
pas trop
non non au niveau des systèmes des
prairies non c'est plutôt au niveau des
systèmes de culture
en gros on peut encore qu'on peut
détruire des prairies avec des petits
shows that any bon j'ai des personnes de
la direction de l'environnement qui font
partie des participants de chauffage
je vais entendre les oreilles sifflent
et je pense plus tard j'ai fait à peu
près le tour des questions je crois au
niveau du début du iv il y à il ya
quelqu'un qui dit qu'on parle beaucoup
de de la limitation des ressources
énergétiques fossiles mais on a très peu
parlé donc de d'autres alternatives est
ce qu'il ya des alternatives au niveau
énergétique pour diminuer donc pour
prévenir donc la supra disparition des
énergies fossiles ou alors la seule
alternative c'est de vivre autrement
c'est plutôt la deuxième réponse c'est
bien comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure en
fait le les énergies fossiles nous ont
sortis du monde des énergies
renouvelables qui étaient les seules
énergies qu'on utilisait il ya deux ou
trois siècles et elles nous ont fait
passer par une phase transitoire où on a
tous plus devenir ironman et
malheureusement ça sera à l'échelle de
la durée de vie de notre espèce puisque
ça fait maintenant pourquoi cent mille
ans qu'il existe au go sapiens est bien
la période des énergies fossiles sur une
période très courte dans l'histoire de
notre espèce
le hockey ce qu est ce qu on là dedans
on a quelques géants vie à quelque
parachute on a un premier parachute qui
est ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité
énergétique c'est à dire le fait d'être
capable d'utiliser plus intelligemment
cette nourriture pour machines en
rendant les machines plus efficace en
étant plus sélectif
peut-être dans les services qu'on leur
demande on a deuxième parachute qui
s'appelle le nucléaire parce que le
nucléaire est une énergie concentrée et
pilotable comme les énergies fossiles
mais elle n'est pas faux cils donc ça
c'est un deuxième parachute et puis on a
un troisième parachute qui est de ceux
[Musique]
acceptés ce qu'on appelle la sobriété
d'accepter une diminution volontaire des
moyens matériels dont on dispose c'est
pas toujours très simple parce que nous
avons notamment une de nos pulsions
primaires j'ai envie de dire qui
s'appelle le statut social le fait de
vouloir grimper dans la hiérarchie est
diminuée délibérément ce qu'on utilise
la taille de notre appartement vous la
taille de maison etc
c'est quelque chose qui va à l'encontre
pour beaucoup de beaucoup d'entre nous
de cette pulsion que nous avons qui est
de plutôt vouloir faire l'inversé donc
la sobriété c'est quelque chose qui ne
se travaille pas avec de la technique ça
se travaille avec des ressorts qui sont
de l'ordre de la sociologie de la
psychologie etc
mais c'est probablement une quelque
chose qu'on soit bien inspirés de
regarder d'un peu près parce que encore
une fois on ne va pas pouvoir
on ne va pas pouvoir échapper à une
décrue énergétique
quand on regarde les ordres de grandeur
de ce que sont capables de faire les et
les énergies renouvelables solaire
éolien et solaire dans les pages de
journaux sont remplis
en fait on se rend compte que jamais
mais vraiment jamais ça ne pourra
remplacer les énergies fossiles et pour
finir il ya quelques questions
donc je pourrais pas faire le bonnet je
pense parce qu'elle soit on est un peu
compliquée pour aborder à les lapider
mais par contre il ya une idée quand
même par rapport au fait parce que on a
l'impression que du fait de la
limitation donc de la croissance par
rapport à la disparition de les énergies
fossiles dont du coup c'est comme s'il y
avait un retour en arrière où il
faudrait réutiliser de la porsche
traction animale il faudrait mettre plus
de travail ou l'énergie main dans le
travail on voit continuer à vivre comme
avant mais en tout cas à vivre peut-être
aussi bien encore voir s'il y avait une
idée qui traverse est des questions par
rapport à ça sur le fait pas de wii que
sans énergie ben pour moi comment on
peut faire pour continuer à produire
notamment en maths et culture est ce
qu'il faudrait utiliser les animaux j'ai
eu plusieurs questions
oui alors je les vois les questions sur
le sujet des grosses exploitations qui
sont plus efficaces que les petites par
kilo produit c'est sûr maintenant les le
but des grosses exploitations c'est
aussi de produire beaucoup plus donc en
fait souvent quand on regarde les
nuisances unitaire ce que les acv
fournissent on se rencontre que ça
pousse à l'intensification mais en fait
l'intensification a notamment pour
conséquence d'augmenter aussi la
production est en général de l'augmenter
plus vite que le gain qu'on peut avoir
sur les émissions militaire donc le
grand paradoxe c'est qu'on peut avoir
globalement des émissions plus faible
avec des émissions unitaire qui sont
plus importantes parce qu'on est dans
des systèmes qui sont moins productifs
donc en fait le vrai sujet il est plutôt
là il est d'essayer de changer les
critères d'optimisation aujourd'hui on a
un critère d'optimisation qui est
purement économique et il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à changer de
critères d'optimisation sinon c'est
évident qu'on s'en sortira jamais
comment est ce qu'on fait pour inciter
la population à venir l'agriculture
c'est une très bonne question
[Rires]
j'aimerais c'est pas la totalité de la
réponse j'ai quelques éléments en tête
il ya un serveur avec un tout parce que
ça va aussi avec l'aménagement du
territoire ça va avec le ça va avec la
rémunération des producteurs sa faim
voilà ça va avec un tout j'ai envie de
dire en le voulant que je puisse faire
mais qui serait aussi la meilleure est
dans un monde dans lequel on pourra pas
tout avoir
je le redis il va falloir faire des
arbitrages donc si on considère que de
remettre du monde dans l'agriculture
c'est plus important que de faire la 5g
et bien à ce moment on arbitre les
sommes disponibles en conséquence ce que
ne fait pas aujourd'hui il y avait un
truc qui m'a beaucoup fait rire je vais
pas même finir par ça parce que je
trouve que c'est un énorme vague de voir
que dans le green deal européen
il ya un énorme paquet de milliards 50
ou 100 qui sont prévus pour le monde
rural pour mettre de l'internet à haut
débit dont je fus pas complètement sûr
que d'avoir des vidéos en haute
définition sur smartphone quand on est
dans le champ vous en montrer ça soit
totalement indispensable il faut
s'asseoir la première priorité dans le
contexte dans lequel on est là pour
qu'on fait avant de passer conclusion la
présidente hélène je sais que la
première étape dans ce changement à
venir
ce serait de sensibilisation aux enjeux
des changements climatiques
et puis d énergie et ça tombe bien parce
que j'ai l'honneur de vous inviter à la
semaine sur le climat organisée par
crainte du 1er au 5 février où nous
allons jouer avec un jeu justement de
sensibiliser à cette problématique
donc je vous invite à je vous tiendrai
au courant et puis je vous inviterai à
inciter tous les gens que vous
connaissez autour de vous à participer à
cette semaine
voilà elana je vais peut-être de baisser
conclu les remercier jean marc robin son
intervention es tu toujours là est ce
que tu peux à vue oui je suis là je suis
là je suis là oui oui merci beaucoup
jean-marc pour vos propos clairs bien
je veux dire tout à fait passionnant
vous êtes passionné donc ça ça c'est
entendu et ça s'est vu merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir accepté de participer à
cette visioconférence
pour conclure je dirai simplement que
quand je vivais remarque qui défie la
droite de mon écran je vais reprendre
celle de sylvain qui dit que deux thèmes
à aborder dans nos groupes suite et
suite à cette soirée en tout cas c'est
chaque fois qu'on initie une formation
une journée d'information ou un débat on
s'aperçoit qu'on est encore plus de
questions à la fin qu'on en avait au
double donc en tout cas merci à tout le
monde d'avoir participé bien sûr nous
nous sommes toujours à la disposition de
chacun nous fr geda si vous voulez
encore rebondir sur cette soirée
on se tient prêt à recevoir vos
remarques et vos questions merci à tous
je veux déjà félicité pour
l'organisation de cette soirée et merci
à notre intervenant avec qui j'aimerais
bien que conversé de la méthanisation
pour remettre quelques logique en place
mais le c'est vrai que c'est pas très
positifs tout ça ce qui nous attend avec
le climat on n'a pas trop de souci pour
nous on en a beaucoup pour nos enfants
nos petits-enfants
on va tous se mobiliser pour atténuer
les les effets nous pour noël que
l'agriculture peut avoir sur le climat
et en captant de plus en plus de carbone
avec nos pratiques agricoles puisqu'on
va tendre tous vers l'agroécologie mais
la vache à sa place de temps le système
est là dessus je suis un peu déçu de ce
que pense jean marc de nos vaches il
qu'elles sont très utiles et le le bilan
le bilan gaz à effet de serre des vaches
est positif c'est vrai qu'elle en dit m
mais nous permettent d'en éviter par la
fertilisation et par l'utilisation des
prairies et ça là dessus je pense que je
suis pas convaincu par les explications
de jean marc sur ce sujet là pour tout
le reste je suis complètement 28 et je
remercie encore luan de nous avons avons
préparé cette soirée
merci aux xve et je pense qu'on aurait
peut-être des collaborations et voilà un
dernier petit mot avant qu'ils
n'embarquent bonbonnes continuer
et effectivement il ya des choses à
faire et à très court terme de soirée
merci à matour montre participation est
très bonne soirée et bonne nuit
un refus bonsoir